Two one he ha.
Hello Anthony.
Jeselnik how are you sir?
Great,
Joe.
Good,
my buddy.
Uh,
you a fully committed to the beard now.
Yeah.
I want to keep it as long as I can.
Are you going to go manage a man or you know,
as trim to trim a little.
I trim it a little bit.
Uh,
I just felt like the lady who cuts my hair trims it every like four weeks when I
go in for a haircut,
but I don't touch it at all.
I'm afraid if I tried to trim it I would just ruin it.
But I've love,
love having a beer.
Why do you love having a beard is like,
it's like sunglasses for the bottom half of your face.
You know what I mean?
Hide from the world kind of.
Yeah.
It chills me out a little more.
Especially on stage.
Like you're,
you're under the lights,
you know?
Uh,
and um,
I,
my lip would start to get a little bit sweaty and I'm thinking about my lip and
I'm like,
should I wipe this?
Should I move it?
And then I started to sweat more.
But now that I have the beard and mustache,
my lip gets a little sweaty.
You can't tell so I don't get more anxious.
Uh,
interesting.
Yeah.
So you used to like think boy,
there's a little couple of beads.
Upper lip.
Yeah.
And I'm like,
can they see it?
Should I wipe?
Is it like,
is it too much?
If I'm wiping I drives me crazy.
You know,
it gets me boogers.
If I think I have a book,
like what is going on with my nose?
What is that?
Is that a booger shit?
Can they see that?
Oh,
I check for sure before I go on stage.
There's always a bigger check.
But I,
I'm so animated and I'm always yelling and screaming.
I'm always worried that something is like hanging off the tip of my nose.
Yeah.
And the people in the front row can't even enjoy it.
Like what the fuck man,
your nose,
Bro.
I've never had that.
I've had like definitely a fly down situation.
Oh yeah.
Never,
never like a booger.
That a ruined the show.
This is two things that people love to laugh at your fly down.
And if you put a beer down on the stage and the foam comes over the top,
I go,
Oh my God,
your beers coming.
Ooh,
those are those things.
Right.
[inaudible] hi,
humor.
Yeah.
Hi.
Humor sweat.
Like,
like weird sweat stains like,
um,
when I've done specials,
but speaking,
which Anthony Jessalyn next new comedy special comes out tonight.
I hear.
Yup.
This evening.
Midnight.
I guess Netflix does it.
Excited.
Very excited.
Wow.
I've been seeing your sad.
It's fucking fantastic.
Thank you.
Thank.
I think this is the best I've ever done,
so I'm uh,
I'm pumped for it.
It's a beautiful thing about comedy,
man.
Keep working.
Keep paying attention to it.
You get better at it.
You don't really,
I mean,
Dom Maria and I had this conversation just a couple of months ago.
He looked Joe,
he goes,
I'm never been better.
He goes,
I'm fucking it.
A thousand years old.
It was,
I've never been better at comedy.
Yeah.
As long as you don't quit,
you don't,
you don't ever get worse.
I don't think.
You don't,
as long as you don't give up because some guys don't quit.
But they give up.
Exactly.
Yeah.
They just go through the same material every single time.
You're like,
w w what are you doing here?
You're just trying to get out of the house.
You're not trying to get better as a little of that.
Yeah.
It's like if you're not right,
I guess that's the difference between also guys who put out specials or I say
women too or,
and people who don't.
Some people just don't put anything out.
Yeah,
no.
Yeah.
Once you put it out,
like I put it out because I'm like,
I'm,
I'm done with this.
Now it's getting boring.
It's not going to get better.
It's good as I can make it,
but because of that,
then I have to come up with a new hour specific schedule.
You like to fall too,
right?
If I'm correct,
I try.
I did it.
I did a year in La,
like at the store every night,
you know,
and like once a month I do Largo and try it all out at once.
And then a,
at the end of that year,
I had about 40 minutes,
went to clubs for a year,
every weekend for a year.
And then once that I had the hour after that,
then I did a year of theaters.
I mean at the end of that year I taped the special and,
and uh,
I was done with it.
So you're on like a three year plan?
Pretty much.
Yeah.
And that might change,
you know,
as I've gotten older,
uh,
the idea of a four year plan sounds a little bit nicer and you have other things
going on that,
uh,
that it's not as,
I'm not as worried.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
Um,
I was trying,
I think two years seems to be right for me,
but it might be better to give it a little more time.
Right.
Just a little bit more time to tighten things up and Polish and you know,
add layers and act,
extra punch.
It's like you,
you know those guys,
like in when I started out in Boston,
there was guys that had been doing in the same set forever and there's pros and
cons to that and the pro is God damn.
They had that shit down tight where it was just punch line,
rapid punchline,
pause,
punchline.
They knew the,
the economy of words was perfect.
There was no fat,
no fat in the bits they had.
They had tightened all that stuff up.
Yeah.
My one of my biggest fears is like taping the special and then coming up with
like a great tag.
You know what I mean?
Like that.
I want it to be done when I shoot it because that feeling is awful.
It's the worst.
Done that.
Yeah.
So by sucks it sucks.
I W I once went back in my last special thoughts and prayers I ADR to line.
I like walked off stage and was like,
oh fuck,
I should use this word.
And I,
it just occurred to me in the moment that I was using the wrong word.
So I went back and ADR you can obviously tell it's like me talking and then it's
like clearly a different voice,
a different voice.
Uh,
just one word but I had,
we'll do ADR stand for,
I know what it means but what does it stand for?
Jamie knows he's an actual audio guy.
Automated Dialogue Replacement and why it's automated is lost in my head
forever.
But that's what it means.
I wouldn't have guessed that in a million years.
I would've never,
I knew what it meant.
I've done ADR.
Yup.
I did it like fear factor.
Like every episode I had it do ADR.
It was the worst.
Why did you,
because you were just mispronouncing names or you it was usually because they
wanted a titan segments up.
Like you know,
we would film for three days and we'd have to slam that down to 44 minutes.
So sometimes you needed or sometimes
they needed clarification for certain things.
Like,
like we would explain the rules to them like very specifically and they would
have to read these rules and it took a long time.
But then like sometimes in the moment,
like on television you wouldn't explain it as clearly.
Like while we're filming,
like when would we had show them like this is what you have to do,
this is what you have to start here.
You go from here to there.
But sometimes when you would want to put it on TV,
wanting to be more precise or more concise.
Yeah.
So I would every fucking week I to do ADR.
I hated it.
You did.
It seems like it would be fun,
like fear factor,
but just ADR seems like easy.
It's relaxed.
You're just in the booth.
Yeah,
I was born.
No,
no,
I didn't mind it.
Yeah.
Now the fun thing about fear factor was when the checks came,
that was a fun thing.
And then when Nice people one,
that was fun too.
Yeah,
those,
those things were fun.
But really that was,
that was a great job.
But it was a job.
It was like a job.
But like,
you know,
if he had a great like,
yeah,
I really like working here.
Whereas you don't really say that about stand up.
No,
I mean,
I don't think about it as a job.
It's just fucking fun.
It's awesome.
Oh,
absolutely.
Absolutely.
It's a get to do.
Yeah.
I get to do.
That's my new thing is like get to do versus have to do.
How long have you been doing it now?
Almost 17 years.
Wow.
Yeah.
Not Crazy to say.
It did,
is,
it blows me away like 17 years just seems like,
seems like forever.
And I'd had it my head that like 20.
Was it an important number?
Like when you get to 20,
that means something.
And I,
I think I must have made that up that people say 10 years is a big deal,
but 20 doesn't seem to,
uh,
like I thought that was like,
that's when you're really relaxed.
10 years seems like you're a pro.
When I see someone,
I'm like,
how long have you been doing it?
11 years.
All right.
I buy it.
And when someone says six years,
I'm like,
good luck.
You might quit.
Yeah.
I hate the people who were like,
I've been doing it for like 12 years.
When's the last time you got onstage?
Uh,
six months ago.
Oh No.
You started doing standup 12 years ago.
Uh,
you have not been doing it.
Yeah.
You gotta go fuck yourself if you're not,
if you take those people that take like giant chunks of time off and then come
back,
you know,
and the want to go on the road with you like,
hey man.
Yeah.
It's like no,
that's not how this works.
You gotta be,
you gotta be putting in the work yourself.
Otherwise,
why,
why am I doing you a favor?
Yeah.
Well it's just,
it's one of those things like if you wanted to run a marathon,
you have to run all the time or you're going to be really,
really sore and tired when it's over,
you know,
and you're not going to really be able to do it.
You want to be able to actually do it and really run.
This is the same as stand up for whatever reason.
It seems so fucking easy when you're watching,
when you're watching someone do it.
See this is one of the reasons why everyone thinks they can do it,
cause it's just,
we're just talking.
It's not like we're doing Cirque de Solei up there and some people are like,
oh,
that's not that funny.
I can be not that funny.
Like it's not that it's not that big a deal.
Yeah.
You could.
Yeah,
maybe.
Yeah.
When you started out,
where'd you would sit?
Did you start in here?
Los Angeles?
Did you really where,
what was your first club?
I,
uh,
my first ever show was at the belly room in the comedy store.
I took the class,
I took a class.
Uh,
Greg Dean,
uh,
I was working at borders books and music was my first job in La.
I remember that,
play it like that big bookstore and I,
they,
I just found the thinnest book on standup comedy that they had and bought that
and uh,
read it at the end.
It was like,
this guy teaches a class and send him Monica.
So you went and people were like,
Oh,
surprise that I took a class.
It's like the class didn't teach me how to be like this.
It just kind of gave me the courage to go to open mics and uh,
and,
and I don't think it could have just gone to an open mic.
I was too scared for that.
I was like 23.
Uh,
but after the class,
you know,
I had a seven minutes set that I would go and go and do.
What did the class teach you?
Like how do they,
how do they start a class out?
There were two sessions.
It was like,
it was like beginning and advanced and they would talk a little bit about joke
structure.
They would talk about like simple things like taking the Mick out of the stand,
you know,
like,
but be careful cause some people walk up and they'd take the teeth out,
you know what I mean?
And like things like don't run the light show up early.
Like things that were just,
um,
I may not have been common sense,
but it like,
it gave me comfort to know the rules so that I could try to break them and you
know,
later on and then did a set at the belly room like with a bunch of other like
people in the class who are all terrible.
None of them are doing standup anymore.
And I like killed.
Like I thought I killed,
I had to tape,
I sent it out to everyone and one of the jokes from that first set I ended up
using in the Donald Trump roast real.
So I was like,
Oh wow,
maybe there's like some gold in there.
And I went back,
you know,
10 years after I did it and watch the set again and had a panic attack watching
myself.
What the way it was in my head was not what was on,
uh,
was not what was on screen.
It was,
it was bad.
Do you think
just like psychological protectants that you throw up,
I mean,
what is it that makes you think that you were better back in the day?
I think it's exciting.
It's excitement,
right.
You know,
and just being stupid,
you know,
like when people get into stand up later on in life,
I'm like,
I don't know if you can do this because you have to kind of be dumb enough to go
through the things you have to do when you start out.
But I'm glad I was 23 when I was running around to open mikes and uh,
and not knowing any better.
That's a really good point.
Yeah.
I was 21 I was really dumb.
Did you even just went right to an open mic or?
Well,
um,
I went to an open mic to watch first and that's what gave me the courage to go
on stage because I had always thought like standup comedy was going to be Jerry
Seinfeld or Richard Pryor.
And if you go there,
like,
you know,
and I had wrote a bunch of stuff and I had practiced a bunch of stuff into a
tape recorder and it was terrible,
but I was trying to say it like a comedian.
But then when I went to an open mic and I realized how bad some of those people
are,
I was like,
well,
I can be that
bad.
I can do that.
I know I can pull off what they're doing.
Yeah.
There's something about like performing for comedians that really angered me.
Like if I'm an audience wasn't laughing,
it was like,
all right,
whatever.
The comedians,
it's like,
no,
you guys should get me.
Really ticked me off.
That I think didn't have any friends in the open mic.
A community that would laugh.
No,
I didn't have friends at all.
Like I would just,
I was just the guy who showed up and,
and did a set and we just get angrier and angrier.
So I would like great because I was mad that they didn't,
they didn't get that I was funny,
you know?
And it was like,
it's my job to prove it to them and I was like,
these people should understand that I'm a,
that I'm funny.
Like,
because suddenly if a comedian that doesn't like me or doesn't like respect what
I do,
I'm just like,
I can't believe you're comedian.
Like,
I really feel that way.
That's a funny way of looking at it.
Well,
it's one of those things where you want to be good,
so bad.
You'll sort of convince yourself that you're good.
Are you convinced yourself that you're better than you are?
Like I remember the feeling of being at an open mic night and not being sure
whether or not I was going to go on stage or not having a spot and watching
these guys go,
God dammit,
I want to go up there.
If I got up in front of that crowd right now,
I could kill you.
Just convince yourself that you were good.
Yeah.
I mean I knew that my performance was bad.
I knew I was like funnier than what I was putting out there and that was what
frustrated me.
It's like I've got to keep writing new jokes to get to,
to be able to prove myself to get to your potential.
Exactly.
Yeah.
Yeah,
yeah.
That's,
uh,
it's a,
it's an interesting thing because it occurs in almost every thing that's
difficult to do is like,
you see the path,
you're like,
okay,
I can just keep going.
Like martial arts for example,
it's a perfect,
perfect example.
It's like you'll practice with a white belt and you kind of think like,
oh,
I kind of get this,
I'm going to get good at this,
I'm going to brew it.
And then you'll practice with someone who's really good,
who does it every day and is a black belt and you just feel helpless and you
feel like,
God damn it,
I'll never get to that spot.
And that I used to feel like that about standing up.
There was a guy,
when I first started out,
you probably never heard of him,
but he's one of the best comics of all time.
His name is Teddy Berge Ron.
And he was a Boston legend and he had a problem with substances to put it
mildly.
And um,
he was,
his timing was impeccable.
He went on the tonight show,
like back in the day,
and he would play piano as well.
And,
uh,
he had like,
like the ultimate set on the tonight show.
I mean just fucking murdered sat on the couch with Johnny,
I mean,
and just was killing it and just super low.
And then went off the rails,
like the pressure of success and everything and his pills and booze and woo and
the whole thing.
But when I was an open mic or,
um,
one of the early,
early sets that I did,
I remember I did a set and then he went on,
you know,
there was a bunch of old micros and then some professionals would hop on and do
like five,
10 minutes.
And he went out and did that and he
was so fucking good and so polished.
I almost quit.
I was like,
what am I doing?
I'm terrible.
I don't have a point of view.
I don't,
I don't have perspective.
I don't have that kind of timing.
I definitely don't have that kind of swagger.
Like he had a,
like a casual swagger,
you know,
on stage.
Did you have like an idol?
Like somebody were trying to be as a standup?
Um,
like he knows are probably a bunch of guys.
I sounded a lot like Richard,
Jenny in the beginning I was kind of stealing,
like almost stealing his timing.
And then I realized that one time,
one time I was on stage and I heard myself sound like him and I was like,
alright,
I gotta fix this.
Yeah.
You know,
I did that with,
with David Tell in New York,
why would I did it till I would run downstairs and watch it tells set.
And then one day I caught myself not doing one of his bits,
but like one of his mannerism kind of things.
Yeah.
It's just fun to do.
And I felt,
I was like,
I gotta stop this.
And I went and told SD,
uh,
the woman who books the comedy cellar,
I was like,
I got to stop watching David Towel.
And I said it like a confessional and I thought she was going to be like,
you're not a real comic.
Then everyone watches the talent.
She goes good,
like more people should stop watching.
David tells people were just ripping them off and I understand why,
but,
uh,
he's got such a bizarre sense of timing and then it's so infectious,
you know?
Oh yeah.
Just so,
so fun.
So fun to watch.
I've known Dave for like 28 years I think,
and he's always been like that.
He's always had that very strange way of talking.
Yeah.
You know?
Oh,
it's a box.
I've known him maybe 10 years and I don't know him at all.
You know what I mean?
We've like talked to a couple of times,
but I don't know anything about the guy.
And I think I met him after he had quit drinking,
so I think it was a different,
oh yeah.
I knew him in the heart when he was on that show.
Insomniacs and he was getting blasted out of his gourd every night.
Every night he was going to these places and it was killing him.
Yeah.
And he stopped doing the show for that very reason because everywhere he would
go,
it would just be shots,
shots,
and uh,
and then he,
one time I ran into him at the Improv and it was like one o'clock in the morning
and I was headed home and he's like,
Hey,
is there an after party?
Where do we go?
I was like,
where do we go?
Like go home,
go to sleep.
Yeah.
And then the next time I saw him,
he was totally sober.
He's one of those guys though that got sober and didn't stop being hilarious.
No,
a lot of guys do.
Yeah.
Oh,
he's sober up and then they become annoying and they want to talk about their
sobriety.
I cannot stand,
I can't stand recovering addicts.
They drug.
Yeah,
man.
They're worse than people who just find yoga.
They just won't shut the fuck up about recovery.
Yeah.
I,
I'm a,
I'm guilty of that with many things.
If I get into something and I can't shut the fuck up about it,
but I get it,
you know,
for them it's like this pivotal moment in their life.
We're all sudden,
they have their shit together and they just want to talk about it all the time.
The thing that drives me nuts though is when they judge.
Yes.
And they always get a little judgey that I go,
you sure?
Like do you need that last drink?
And I'm like,
yeah,
I do.
And I can handle my shit.
So,
Hey,
I'm super sorry.
You got that fucked up gene.
Yeah,
yeah,
whatever.
You went too far with it.
But I've got it under control,
like being a little buzzed and I'm luckily the drugs and the drinking that I do,
it's a,
you know,
I,
if I'm going to drink,
I drink high quality stuff,
uh,
smoke a little weed,
but the other drugs don't really do it for me.
Tiff,
you fucked with other drugs.
Do tried just about everything.
And it just like,
not for me.
Like I've done cocaine and the next day been like,
I just feel stupid.
Like I feel like everything that came out of my mouth last night was dumb.
I feel like hell,
uh,
I enjoy,
we'd chills me out a,
I like beer and wine and,
and uh,
and vodka and whiskey.
I have not done a lot of things.
I've never done masculine or pot.
It's basically,
I think they're pretty much the same thing.
I've never done,
um,
coke and never done meth.
I've never done any real and fed amines.
I've,
I mean,
I've always been scared of those though,
because those are the ones that I've seen people like really lose their lives
for.
Yes.
And I,
I don't mess with them.
Fed it means at all and I don't enjoy it.
Uh,
someone who grinds their teeth,
you know,
like that's,
that's awful.
And I found like with comedy,
you can't be funny on cocaine
at comics who do,
who do cocaine and our funding because I just find it to be like,
you're not,
I can't laugh at anything and I can't,
like,
I'm talking too fast.
My timing's off.
Uh,
and like,
I'm not thinking in a funny way that I've always been surprised.
The comics who have coke problems.
Yeah.
Joey Diaz talked about that,
cause Joey Diaz did coke for years,
but he doesn't,
he's never done coke and gone.
I said,
she goes,
he goes,
every time I tried it I was fucking terrible.
He goes,
it takes away your soul,
your heart.
You've got no heart when you're up there.
Yeah.
I guess again,
I've never done it,
but what I get is just,
I get that whole speedy thing where you just like your,
your sense of how people are perceiving you as distorted timing is distorted.
Yeah.
Like I don't even go on stage.
Hi,
I'm Matt.
I have a couple of beers.
I don't want to be slurring.
I even smoked pot at all that day.
It's a worst show for it.
Really?
Yeah.
I wonder why that is.
I think I'm just,
I'm just in my own head.
You know,
it makes,
it makes me want to get through the set as opposed to being present and enjoying
it.
Like I just want it to be over so I can go chill out.
You know?
That's interesting.
It's only on only with weed.
One of my favorite things to do and I would take us in the row with me.
He's getting so high that they could barely talk and then put him on stage.
That's what I do.
The first,
the first two guys I would open for on the road,
it was a Doug Benson and Brian Posehn,
Jesus Christ.
And they were like,
they wanted to smoke all day.
That I was like,
every time I was a feature act like little most every time I was a feature act,
I was terrible because I thought like,
I have to smoke,
I've have to spoke to these guys that they won't take me on the road,
but I'm like barely getting through this half hour and I'm terrible.
It's not a smart
move for someone who's just getting going to be that high on sage.
But one time I did,
I was,
uh,
I,
I really didn't smoke pot until I was 30,
like really smoke pot.
But I did it a handful of times when I was younger.
And one time when I was like a 21,
I was living with my buddy Jimmy.
And,
uh,
him and his,
one of his friends came over and he had pot and we smoked some pot during the
day.
I think we had a barbecue or something and then I had a gig like six hours later
I was still high and I remember being on stage and my timing was excellent and I
was so locked in and focused and I remember being terrified that I was going to
be terrible.
Terrified,
but I really nailed it for whatever reason.
But then I never did it again and I was like,
fuck,
I got away with it,
you know?
And then I started smoking when I was 30 and it kind of changed my act.
Like it made my ag from like,
it made my act more introspective.
I started talking about weird or subjects and more interesting I taught,
I started talking about things that it was actually more interested in.
Did you start to write on stage more when you were high on stage?
Yeah,
I kind of always have written on stage a little bit,
but mostly,
um,
mostly like tangents.
Like I'd go off on a weird branch if I knew how to get back to the river,
right.
I would take like a weird stream off to the right and then just as long as I
knew how to get back to the river of whatever the fuck I was talking about,
I'd be fine.
But when I'm high I'll just let go wandering through the woods like I'm not,
I'm not even concerned about the river.
I'm like,
yeah,
you know there's the river of thought,
the pattern that you're following.
But when I'm high I'm like,
what?
But who the fuck wants that and the why?
Why would you be that person?
And then I'll start thinking like I remember when I was a kid and then I'll just
like add a nowhere,
have this idea and I'm hoping it's going to go somewhere.
And those moments I feel like they're like,
it's like
foraging for food.
Like occasionally you find it,
like if you go out looking for mushrooms,
you don't know where they are.
You might find edible mushrooms.
Hopefully you're going to find them and sometimes you won't.
Sometimes you come home with an empty basket,
but sometimes you get him and the only way you find out is if you forage.
And that's kind of what it feels like when I'm high on stage.
It's like,
Ugh,
okay.
I guess Kona.
But then I'm also really worried that I'm going to be boring.
Like I want to be.
Uh,
uh,
no.
These people paid to see,
I know I'm trying to develop material,
but I also know I'm entertaining these people in the present.
So it's like a fine line.
Yeah.
I don't have that confidence to waste the audience's time.
Do you know what I mean?
Like I'll see Chris Rock,
Chris Rock's a friend of mine and he'll go up and just like with nothing and
just sit there and very comfortably for 45 minutes and just,
and just,
and just kind of talk and look for things and has no problem with it whatsoever.
And I let him,
he'll go,
what else?
What else?
And the like stare at the sky,
look
at the ground.
I can't,
you know,
who was the master at that was Damon Wayans.
Oh my God.
Who a lot of people have forgot a lot of people forgot was one of the FEC and
still is one of the best comics ever.
Damon Damon was a god damn murderer in the nineties.
Oh,
I loved her coming up,
but I remember going to the hot cafe.
Uh,
they would do it like a show every Tuesday.
Then my friends would run and Daymond winds would always drop in and do an hour
and ruin the show.
Like he would have no material and he would just attack people in the crowd.
By the time he was offstage,
like the audience was furious like they were,
they went crazy when he came out and then by the end they were just like,
why is he doing this to us?
And we were like,
we were like,
oh fuck Damon Waynes this year.
It was so funny.
Somebody like looked up to as a kid and like loved you.
Just like,
aw man,
this asshole again.
Wow,
that's crazy.
I wonder why he was doing that.
But I mean,
I guess it was probably because he couldn't do it at the store anymore.
Yeah.
W how,
how many years ago was this?
God,
I mean,
the least,
at least 10,
12,
13 years ago.
See,
that puts it.
That's,
that makes sense,
right?
Because that's around 2005 yeah.
That's like probably he stopped going to the store.
The store probably tightened up the way they used to because they used to just
let anybody just draw.
Like Eddie Griffin would drop in,
wasn't on the,
wasn't on the schedule.
He would drop in at 9:00 PM and get off stage at 3:00 AM and that was real.
Yeah.
That was real six hours.
That would kill me.
And uh,
and then when he was done,
he be like,
who's next?
Who's next day?
He didn't six hours.
What's the longest that you've ever done?
I think an hour and 40 minutes.
Maybe a little longer.
I don't remember,
but I think an hour and 40 minutes.
Probably the longest I've ever done.
Yeah.
But that's too long.
Too Long.
Yeah.
An hour and 20 is more than anybody should ever have to hear you talk.
And even that,
it's like pushing it.
What I like.
I like,
I like to do,
when I do like a theater I two an hour or an hour and 10 and I just want,
I just want to just start and then finish,
just come on,
go ready.
And then for one hour I want everything to be tight and concise and I would way
rather have an hour and 10 minutes that people really enjoyed versus an hour and
a half where they're like an hour of it was really funny because then it leaves
you with this even if it's the same hour,
that extra time.
I also just think the audience doesn't want to see more than an hour of comedy.
And it's like people were like,
oh I did three hours the other night.
Like why?
Like the audience must have hated it.
Like Chapelle used to drop into the cellar.
He liked Dan Cooper going back and forth.
Like who could do the longer set logs ever world record,
like world records.
Yeah.
And then I think Bob Marley eventually broke it or something.
Uh,
Bob Marley from Maine.
Yeah.
Didn't he do like two days on stage?
Funky bitches.
And,
uh,
but it,
Chappelle was down there one time when I was like,
Oh,
I'm gonna go check it out.
And it was like almost unwatchable because it was like the pacing that they have
that you have to do in order to be on stage that long.
And he was funny,
but it would be like not funny for long stretches than a big punch line.
And then back into it.
The you're like,
all right,
like the show Dave was on hiatus,
right?
That was when Dave kind of like took time off a comedy for a long time.
He Co,
I mean kind of like he wasn't doing specials,
but I think he was doing like surprise shows.
Like he was always,
always kind of on tour in weird venues.
He's still doing that now.
You know,
he's not always doing like big,
big giant theaters.
So like he'll just want a book,
like a 20 seat room and uh,
make as agents crazy.
Well,
he's been doing,
he's been doing the lab at the Improv,
that little tiny room,
which is what,
50 50 seats maybe.
Yeah,
he did it as zs did it.
That's a,
that's a place for comedy dies.
That little fucked up room.
I have always hated that room.
That room sucks.
Every deck on the planet.
When people are like,
oh you can try new stuff.
It's like I can try the new stuff in the main room for a good crowd.
Like why do I want to do this little terrible room?
I don't know why it's even the,
well it's a weird one was cause the belly room is perfect.
The belly room works.
Yeah,
but somewhat for some reason that lab seems like why is there a comedy here?
What is,
why is the door right there?
Why is this treat right there?
What is this?
Yeah.
What is this here?
What do you got going on here?
Everything about it.
It's like I was trying to tell them,
I go turn that into the comics green room.
Like no,
there's good comedy.
Then I'm like,
shut your mouth.
You shut your mouth.
You turn that into the comics cream room.
Yeah.
They used to be where the bar was from my now they used to be like where
everybody's hanging out before the show.
It was great.
It was great,
and he'd go in the other room and to go on stage and you would go from that part
to go on stage.
Now everybody goes from the front door to go on stage,
so you're trapped in that little hallway and you're like,
where the fuck?
How do I,
where do I hide?
There's nowhere to hide.
That's why I love the stores so much because there's so many places to hide,
but the store has a little problem with the,
or like when you,
right before you're about to go on stage,
you're in the hallway and he had only at the hallway,
but I liked those seats against the back.
That just for comics do.
You can kind of sit there and go over your notes and we'll leave you alone.
I love that backbar.
Yeah,
back bars.
My favorite,
the back bars,
the shit,
the secret comedians bar.
I mean that's just what they've done in the new,
this new generation of managers and the people that run the place now they've
sort of like really paid attention to like what,
what's going to make these guys happier?
What's going to make this better?
Like you gotta give him a place where they can hide.
So given that back bar and you'd go to the back part any day,
it's filled with people just hanging out,
talking shit and like,
it's fun.
It's like a fun play.
I go there,
I gravitate and I get into the back end.
I'm like,
Oh,
look at all these cool people.
Yeah.
This is a great spot to hang out it.
They did that.
They added security.
They did it.
So it's,
it's night and day two,
the way it used to be.
I never used to go there.
I didn't like hanging out there.
I didn't like any part of it.
And then once,
uh,
once the new management took over,
I was like,
oh,
great.
Like
I once did a show there,
I did a benefit.
There was like a kid who died,
I forget his name,
he was a comic,
uh,
died in a car accident and they had like a benefit for his family.
Oh yeah.
That's Josh.
Adam Meyers friend.
Well,
Angelo.
Yeah.
Angela.
Angela Bowers.
I did not know him.
I didn't know him either,
but uh,
he was like a fan of mine and I was like,
I was like his favorite comic they could get and I'm like on the,
I'm on the marquis,
it's a sold out show.
I have a great set.
I walk off and Tommy comes up and he's like,
uh,
the old manager was like,
Andy,
that was great when we got,
we've got to get you around you.
You got,
you've got to start hanging out,
you know,
you got to start hanging out and doing,
do you know,
doing the open mic and stuff.
And I'm like [inaudible] my name is on the marquee right now.
You just watched me headline the show.
Like what are you talking about?
And I then the,
I don't think I ever saw him again.
Next thing I knew he was fired and they were like,
what can we do to,
to get you back here?
Well that's Adam,
right?
Adam did the same thing to me.
He told me that Tommy got fired and came to visit me.
The improv.
So you were gone seven years,
seven years from the store.
And then when Tommy left,
they brought you back in?
Well,
there's two reasons.
One,
I had to go physically to the store because Ari was filming his comedy central
special and is like that.
He's a,
you know,
he's just one of my best friends.
And I knew him from the time he was a doorman and I knew that him filming his
special there was so important and there's no hours can it miss it?
I was like,
I have to be here,
like I have to see this at the store.
So I was like,
oh fuck.
All right,
I gotta go back.
And so I decided to go back.
I think he was filming on a Wednesday.
What,
what night is a gross battles on Tuesday,
right?
So I went down there on a Tuesday.
I said,
let me go down on Tuesday just to see what's up.
And I went to roast battle and I was like,
Holy Shit,
this place is electric.
This is crazy.
Like the environment is so much different.
It's so creative.
And the,
the night that I was at Rose Battle was fucking fantastic.
It was so good.
There was so many funny roasters and I remember thinking,
wow,
this place is just different,
man.
It just feels so much different.
And it wasn't like it is now.
Like now,
like you'll go on a Saturday night,
they'll have six sold out shows,
they have two shows in the belly room,
two and the o r two in the main room.
Everything's sold out and packed with headliners and it's chaos.
It wasn't like that.
It was still sort of shitty like in terms of like the numbers,
but the vibe and the creativity was way different.
And the new guys and girls that were coming up,
they were fucking good man.
I was like,
wow,
this is a different vibe.
I had been gone for almost a decade.
Yeah.
So that brought me in.
I,
like I said,
I had to be there for Ari.
There was no way I,
there's no way I could miss it.
I had to be there.
So I'm like,
all right,
I just got to swallow it.
And that was probably what Adam for sure helped,
but I might've stayed away forever if it wasn't for Ari.
I just had to see it.
Do you like roast battle?
Do you like judging that?
I cringe sometimes cause they're so fucking mean.
Yeah,
sometimes people are so mean,
you know?
Um,
uh,
but I do like it.
I do love the writing aspect of it.
I love the fact that it's a joke writers forum but I don't want to name any
names of this one comic that I'm friends with that does really well and roast
battle and I said,
hey man,
how come you,
when you roast you have all this good new material but you're doing the same
stupid shit when you go on stage all the time.
Like you were doing the same set for years.
You're not,
you're not advancing cause you're not writing a lot,
but you're writing a lot when you write for roasts and I'm like you should treat
like your material.
Like the same way you treat your material when you have to roast.
I,
the thing about the roast is like say if a you are going to roast with Tony
Hinchcliffe,
you guys know each other,
you know who you're writing for.
I,
Tony,
what does he look like?
He looks like,
you know,
you start fucking around with all I know this about Tony and that about towing.
This is going to be funny and it forces you to be creative.
Whereas I think there's so many guys that they,
they develop,
um,
a framework of a set and then they just kind of like that.
That is their comfort.
The comfort is in the fact that they know,
even if it's not good,
they know that they can go from this to that and that this,
and they know where they're going and they don't,
they're not lost.
You know?
And I think that the beautiful thing about the roast is none of that material
you can do in any other place,
you can only do it right there.
So you have to work on that.
And so oftentimes you see like what comics capable of when they're roasting
versus what they're doing when they're actually doing the real set,
which seems stale.
Yeah.
I feel like it's almost,
um,
I agree with everything you're saying that it's almost like a,
it's not beneficial to be like a really good bad roast battle and not as a
stance like it takes,
it can take away from stand up and people think it's like this,
this path to glory and I'm not sure that it is.
No,
I don't think it is.
I think it's a
exercise if you're,
if you're treating all of your comedy,
the way you treat the roast battle,
like you're always working on it.
But I think there's a lot of guys just aren't working on,
I think part of our problem is this no other art form like stand up where
there's low.
Like you were telling me,
you were saying how you took a class to learn to get on stage,
but you were quick to add and almost every great comic does this and he really
didn't learn anything in that class but now,
but it got you to the stage.
That's weird that there's nothing like the best education that we have is
talking to each other.
Like,
like,
how do you write?
How do you do it?
And I'm always,
I've been doing comedy 30 years and I'm always like,
how do you do it?
What are you doing?
What are you doing this?
Why are you doing it that way?
What do you write?
Do you write it out?
Like,
and everybody's got a different thing.
Like bill bird doesn't write anything out,
just his notes and works it out on stage.
You know,
he writes it,
he has these ideas in his head and then he rants and you know,
he uses podcast to develop a lot of his material because his podcast is unique
in that it's just him talking.
But everybody's got a different thing and there's no one who's right.
No one's no one's right.
Was it standing up with said that if you tell,
if you give a comic advice,
you're just telling them how to be more like you [inaudible] you know that I
kind of agree with it.
You can say like write more,
get on stage as much as you can.
You know,
that's important.
But there are things even in comedy that like you hear early on the,
it takes 10 years to understand,
you know,
like I remember the movie,
uh,
um,
the movie comedian with Jerry Seinfeld was like a huge influence on me and
there's one point where Seinfeld's kind of depressed and he's like,
Colin Quinn's like,
what's the matter?
He's like,
I just don't know when I'll be back.
You know,
when I'll feel like I'm back again with this new material.
And Colin Quinn says,
uh,
when you're onstage and you're killing and you're miserable,
that's when you'll,
you'll know your back.
Like we were just like,
great,
I'm making these idiots laugh.
And Seinfeld was dying laughing and I have like,
I saw that and I didn't understand what he meant.
And now I know exactly,
you know.
Well,
if I could go back to when that was filming,
I would grab horny Adams and go,
don't do it.
Don't let them do this to you,
man.
How long have you been doing comedy?
Don't let them do this.
They're going to put you that they're doing this to make Jerry look better.
Don't let him do it.
[inaudible] I mean he must've thought it was like the biggest thing in the world
for him.
Uh,
and I'm so mad.
Like I love that movie.
I watched the DVD once a year and there's no Arnie Adam's commentary track.
They shouldn't give him one.
I think they don't reference it.
Like in the other comment,
there'll be only,
we'll talk about this in his,
and I think he was so angry with the way he was portrayed that he refused to do
one.
He'll be here.
They portray,
I mean they just edited him it the worst aspects of it.
They didn't want to give a nuanced perspective on who he is and what he's doing.
They just wanted him to be like the young guy who's trying to figure it out
versus the old,
you know,
legend
[inaudible] but they would like,
my friends would use them as an example.
Like if I was like acting like a jerk,
they'd be like,
you're behaving like pointing at him.
Like you need to like I came in second and like a comedy competition and I was
mad about it and they were like,
don't be like a warning.
And I was like,
thank you.
Got It.
Well he's doing great now.
I mean already is doing far but I've met him a couple of times.
He's,
he's,
he's always been nice to me.
It's nice guy.
I once did a show at the Improv was years ago and it's an eight o'clock show.
I'm the,
I'm,
I'm not the headliner,
the owner's going on after me,
but it's like I'm the biggest name on the,
on the marquee and I get there and there's six people in the audience and two of
them were like friends of mine who had never seen me perform and I was like,
this is humiliating.
I was like,
what?
I'm like yelling at the staff and like,
how do you have six people here at 8:00 PM on a Friday?
I can go to the store right now and it's,
the five rooms are sold out like what's going on?
And I get onstage and I'm so embarrassed to my friends who see me that I'm
yelling at the staff.
Staff members are walking by and I'm screaming at them like yelling at the sound
guy,
don't even,
I don't even do a joke.
I like put the mic down.
I'm like
fuck this place.
I'm never coming back.
And I leave and I see my friends a couple of days later and I'm like,
so sorry about that.
They're like,
no,
you were funny.
They go,
the guy who went after you,
that guy was angry and I'm like,
that guy was angry.
I yelled at the sound guy for 15 minutes.
Like,
what the hell did he do?
The improv had those dark moments.
They still kind of do sometimes like shop did a show there recently on Friday
night it was 25 people in the crowd.
I blew up at uh,
like the new booker there.
They called me up and then like,
we would love to have you back as we see her at the store.
What can we do to get you back at the Improv?
And I'm like,
email me once a once a week and tell me what spots you have.
And I'll tell you when I can go.
Like,
all right,
like I'm booked for Wednesday,
I see the lineup,
it's like me five people,
Tiffany Haddish.
I'm like,
great.
Should be good.
Show Day of the improv emails me and they're like,
listen,
Tiffany Haddish wants to do an hour and she wants you to introduce her,
so it's just going to be the two of you guys know Mc.
And I'm like,
did you just bump me down to opening act like without and not asking if this is
okay,
just like you're now the MC going up cold,
uh,
that I was.
And I'm like,
all right,
I'll be there,
but know that I'm furious.
And they're like,
why aren't you just cancel?
And I'm like,
because I want you to know how mad I am and I'm never coming back here.
And Tiffany was great.
That was nice to her.
Uh,
but I was just,
I couldn't believe that they would treat me with like that.
I'm there tomorrow night at the Improv.
I'm there all the time.
Yeah.
You want to do a set that maybe don't sold out.
Sold out.
Actually I got a,
I'm going to dinner to celebrate the special dam.
Yeah,
it's good if you catch it with a packed crowd.
It's just they didn't have the right approach to,
to marketing.
Yeah.
That's all it is.
But it used to,
when I first started,
that was the club.
That was where I went when I left the store.
When I left the store for seven years,
I did my sets at the Improv at the ice house.
Haha.
I did.
I'm just anywhere else.
But the store laugh factory?
No,
no,
no.
Never.
They film you.
Yes.
Yeah.
And they put people up when they put,
they've done it with me.
They put your shit up online and they say they don't do it anymore but it's too
late.
You can't just do that.
Yeah.
And their attitude about it was very disappointing.
Like when I told them that I wanted to take my shit down,
they,
they were not,
they weren't,
they weren't understanding or apologetic until it became a big deal.
Yeah.
Like big deal.
Like,
you know,
like how to get other people involved.
It was not good.
It's not wise to think that you could just film people and put them online when
they're working out for free.
Yeah.
Especially like a guy like you who's going to do a fucking Netflix special,
so you're going to release this stuff and put it online long before Netflix gets
ahold of it.
And the attitude about it,
it just wasn't good.
I mean,
it's a great club.
I've worked there many,
many times.
I just don't do it anymore.
Yeah.
You know,
just
get it together.
You know this,
this is the fucking big leagues.
We're in Hollywood.
This is not like some fucking shit hole comedy club in the middle of nowhere
that nobody goes to.
This is on the sunset strip.
This is in Hollywood.
And you're doing that,
like,
what do you guys,
what are you doing?
Yeah.
You couldn't trust them.
It just was ridiculous.
But it's a great club.
Me Go there and you'll see great comedy.
It's,
it's a fucking killer set up.
You know,
it's,
there's a lot of the pieces are in place for it to be amazing.
Yeah.
I was going back for a little bit,
but they would like,
they would use me to promote the whole show.
It's a good thing cause if it's just my show,
right,
I'm just doing 15 minutes and making the same money as everybody else in the
lineup.
Like if I'm at the comedy store,
it's like me,
you delete a Sebastian.
Like you don't feel that pressure and we're all in it together kind of thing.
That it,
I,
I enjoyed the store a lot more than just the way they promote.
I feel less pressure.
Yeah.
The quality of the comedy is better.
And at the store,
and this is like,
there's something about that that I think is like one of the things that's
happened from the seven years ago or the seven years when I was gone versus now,
which I've been back like almost four years.
It'll be four years,
November of five years.
November is that,
um,
it's better for me to see guys like you and to see guys like Neil Brennan and,
and all these,
the asis working with killers,
just,
just this lineup of like where I know that if there's 400 people in that
audience,
they're coming to see everybody.
They're not just coming to see me.
And I think that's,
that's critical for developing material.
I think it's critical for putting,
piecing stuff together and putting an act together.
It's like I need a balanced audience.
I don't want to perform for the,
the converted,
you know what I mean?
Exactly.
Like if I,
like I,
I feel like the store is like a gym where you're working out where like you're
not getting the same,
I don't get the same laughs at the store that I do.
If I go to Largo and every single person there has paid 30 bucks just to see me
so that like,
it makes it easier.
But because I've worked at the store like you,
it's like I've earned that at Largo.
Yeah.
But if I just did Largo all the time and that was it,
I wouldn't be as good.
You know,
you need to kind of,
you need to suffer a little bit.
So nice
at Largo.
[inaudible] I did,
I did Whitney show at Largo and uh,
it was,
it was so,
so nice.
And then,
uh,
I did this bit about mocking feminists and I could say like,
I don't like feminists for the same reason why I don't like white people or only
into white people.
Like I like people who like everybody,
like I'm,
I'm not interested in anybody who's really only into one thing,
you know,
like,
come on,
stop.
Yeah.
Like it's nonsense.
Like I do,
do women need equal rights?
I fucking course of course.
Yeah.
But I don't want to hear you talk about it all the time.
It's annoying.
And you could see like the tightening up,
like someone saying that they don't like feminists.
Like it's like,
oh,
you guys are indoctrinated.
I see what this is.
And so then I felt like,
and it helped me actually develop this one piece that I was doing and that be
like sort of around it rounded out this one piece I was doing because it was
trying to figure out a way that I could explain it to someone who might have a
preconceived notion about who I am,
like the,
to to say it in a way that makes people that were hesitant,
laugh,
you know what I mean?
Versus savages at 1130 on a Saturday night that are hammered.
Yeah.
So Whitney Cummings crowd wasn't a endear.
Antifeminist still laughed.
They laughed because the punchline was good and I had a place to go with it and
the place to go was ultimately mocking men's rights activists.
That was the,
the real thing was the,
the,
this,
the setup for that joke is,
I don't like anybody's into one thing and I go,
but what tries to be the most fucking crazy is men's rights activists.
And like every men's rights activist I ever met,
I just want to grab them and go,
dude,
we got them all.
Yeah.
We got all the rights.
Yeah,
we got them all.
I can't believe that's a real thing.
Men's rights activists,
it's a real thing.
If you get divorced and you have child,
uh,
it's uh,
for child custody,
those things or do those things are real.
Like guys really,
I know men who have gotten really fucked over in divorce where their wife hired
a fucking killer lawyer and they drag them through.
See the thing about,
and I learned this from Phil Hartman,
unfortunately before he died,
uh,
I was trying to tell him to get divorced and I said,
just give her half man,
you'll make more money.
He goes,
it's not half.
it's two thirds.
He goes to fucking lawyers,
take a third.
It's a Goddamn scam.
You know,
he like,
he was furious about it because apparently he had been trying to figure it out,
like how to do it.
But I had a friend whose wife,
ex wife dragged it out on purpose because she wanted him to pay the legal bills.
So he had to pay for her lawyer.
He had to pay for his lawyer and then he had to pay for all of the Times that
she decided to change the goalposts and mu and renegotiate like just no one can
say that you can't renegotiate.
So she would just renegotiate and just drag things out.
And her,
her goal was to try to drain him financially.
So she was doing this on purpose,
like targeting.
So he was essentially paying for the general of the army that was plotting to
murder him.
And he was slowly going crazy and I was watching my friend go crazy and it took
several years for it to be completely resolved and he's still paying her,
he's still,
but he's been divorced for I think 12 years now and he's still pays her.
She didn't have a child and he has a family now.
He's married with children now.
He,
and he still pays this person still.
Like he fucked her so hard.
She can't work 12 years later.
Yeah,
it's so that's where men's rights activists have a point because if you're in a
state that's particularly a progressive or liberal in regards to alimony and
child support,
the only,
the only thing that we win on that,
it's like Tom Arnold,
like we got one on the board for Tom Arnold when he divorced,
but the problem with that is I love Roseanne more than I love Tom Arnold.
No offense Tom.
But I do,
you know,
so like it bothered me that Roseanne had to pay him like,
Bro,
get the fuck Outta here.
You,
you can work like why?
How come we you with a successful person if that's successful person says
fucking kicked,
Brex get outta here.
You have to pay them that that person has to pay the person.
They're getting rid of what?
Oh,
he's used to her lifestyle.
What?
That,
that,
that I'm used to it is a thing.
Yeah.
It's the only thing that makes sense is childcare.
That makes sense.
Like,
Hey,
this person is taking care of the children.
They're your children.
You guys had these children together.
You have to contribute to the,
the,
the money that it costs to raise a child.
100% I get it.
What?
I don't get his alimony.
I just don't get it.
We're not together anymore.
Now how we were before we were together and you didn't have any money and then
you met me and now I have money and then you,
you got used to having money.
Well,
you're going to have to get used to not having money because now you don't have
any money because now we're not together anymore.
Or like a year maybe.
You know what I mean?
Like Dave let her take some time to get back on her feet.
Right.
But a prostitute or anything.
Yeah.
You don't have to be just bitterness.
It's like,
I want to take you for everything that I can.
What am I friends with?
Who's going through a divorce?
He was like,
all my friends who've gotten a divorce,
I mean,
80% of them,
if they have kids,
the wife accuses the husband of molesting the kids.
Oh,
Jesus.
Just for visitation,
you know,
just,
just like for negotiation with this.
Yeah,
exactly.
Well the lawyers are onto that now.
You know,
I mean,
this is actually something that my friend was warned of when the him and him and
his wife were splitting up like,
is your wife malicious?
Will she,
you know,
make some sort of a baseless accusation?
And he's like,
how so?
And then they went into that.
Yeah man,
there's evil people out there that,
and there's also this thing that happens when people break up with someone if
someone wants it doesn't want to be with you anymore.
Someone that you deeply loved and cared about.
You want them to suffer.
It's weird.
I mean it's normal.
So I guess it's not that weird,
but the,
the evil vicious jealousy,
you know,
like you see that vicious jealousy and chimpanzees,
like one of the things that chimpanzees do when the attack people,
one of the things they attack people over is unfairness.
Like a,
there was a terrible story about a guy who had kept a pet chimp and then brought
the a chimp a birthday cake on his birthday.
Brian Posehn has a whole bit about,
it does,
it does.
Even though,
yeah.
Um,
and the other chimps found out that this chimps getting a birthday cake and they
saw it and they weren't getting any cake and they were fucking furious.
So someone had inadvertently left one of the gates open.
So the chimps got out toward this guy apart because of a birthday cake.
But it's that thing.
It's not like it was affecting them.
I was like,
he was doing something bad to them.
So they got out and killed him.
No,
they ripped his dick off because they didn't like the fact that gave the other
champ a birthday cake.
Took his dick,
took his fingers,
took his feet.
But yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
[inaudible] bits.
So funny.
He's like,
the worst thing about that story for that guy is that everyone's gonna want to
hear it forever because it starts with,
so it was bringing a birthday cake to a chimpanzee and then you got to hear the
rest.
But that,
that anger and jealousy,
like there's evolution does an evolutionary basis for it.
Oh,
is that what he looks like now?
Oh my God.
Am I going to show it?
It's tough.
His fingers are missing.
His face has ms and he's got one eye.
His nose is gone.
I'll look at that.
Frown
faces ripped apart the stitched it together that way.
Awful.
Yeah.
It's fucking awful,
man.
Yeah.
You can't own a chimp crazy assholes.
They're the most vicious of all the primates.
Next to people I think.
Good for.
Like you can put like train them for like the first like five years of their
life and then they forget everything.
They just decided they're going to fuck you up.
Yeah.
And they're so strong.
What does that one doing?
Is that the chimp?
No,
no,
but it just popped up in the same group of pictures of shoes.
Hairless chimp.
There's some meaning such a,
it's such a mean species.
You know,
there's a problem with Calibus monkeys in parts of Africa where chimps live
because they've eaten so many columns.
Monkeys that there the populations down 97%.
Yeah.
They rip them apart and eat them a lot while they're alive.
Are they tiny cubs monkeys?
It's not big.
Big enough to eat,
but,
uh,
is a David Attenborough documentary from the 90s where they first discovered
that chimps eat monkeys.
They really didn't know.
They thought the chimps were basically herbivores.
And then they got this video footage of them hunting these monkeys and the way
they would corralled them and beat them through the trees and then catch them.
And this monkey screaming while this chimp is ripping it apart from the hips,
let just chewing it and pulling it apart from the,
and he's like,
and he's like basically ripping his legs and his ass end off and just eating it
alive.
Got Sam.
They're fucking mean man.
They're fucking mean.
It's a mean animal.
But w w what I get,
the fact that,
look,
everything's mean in the jungle.
There's big cats and poisonous snakes and spiders and it's just a hard,
hard,
hard world.
But the thing that drives that gets me is the jealousy because I don't think
other animals experience jealousy the way chimps do.
Is that it right there,
uh,
from the Attenborough that I ended up where they actually caught it?
Yeah.
So that's a monkey in his hand.
Jesus.
Yeah,
Dude.
The videos of it killing it while they're pulling it apart.
Like,
Whoa,
but the,
that jealousy that I want,
you just suffer.
I didn't get that fucking cake.
Oh,
you don't got
me have that cake.
I can't get any cake.
I'm going to pull your fucking Dick off on a bite your nose off like that.
That is a,
as a strange trait for an animal to have.
Oh yeah.
No,
I mean I think it's a terrible trip for a human being to have.
Oh yeah,
we are animals.
Yeah.
It's something,
uh,
you got to work on,
but when it comes to divorce,
like that's that same thing.
It's like that same,
I want you it all fucking software or I want to pull your deck off and that's
why people hire,
hit men and shit to kill their ex wives and killed her ex husband's Liam.
People don't get less crazy as they age.
No,
no,
no.
A lot of times they get more,
cause they never realized.
It's almost over the ride's over and now you know,
you're 65 year old lady.
No one's a fuck you and your 65 year old man,
no one's a fuck you either.
And now all of a sudden you guys are battling,
you know?
Yeah.
Battling over finances and this and that.
I can't be the best years of my life.
That's my favorite.
I did.
I did a girl once and when we broke up she said,
I wasted all this time with you.
I said,
oh I go,
I thought we were dating.
Yeah.
I didn't know you were investing.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
Wasted it.
Oh,
you wasted it.
Well
I guess every relationship when it's over is a waste.
Like what?
That's so bizarre,
bizarre way of looking at it.
Enjoy the present.
Enjoy the time you had together.
Yeah.
But if you thinking about in terms of like hitching a ride on a successful
train.
Yeah.
If your goal is to get married and you're with someone for five years and then
they break up the,
Oh,
you know,
I should be with someone else and you would have married me.
Now I've got to find someone else.
Yeah.
The jealousy thing about the breakup,
it's so,
it's so normal.
It's so hard for people to not be jealous.
Like very few people ever break up and go,
hey man,
she's cool.
It just didn't work out.
I was Dick.
She was,
she needed some growing.
We needed,
we both needed time away.
Hey,
I wish her well.
I've never really gotten jealous.
Like I always like when they move on,
you know what I mean?
When like when they get a new boyfriend,
you're just like,
oh thank God.
That's cause you're a comic.
You have opportunities,
but it's like,
it's like you're not their responsibility anymore.
You know what I mean?
They can still like,
if they're single,
they can still call you up,
you know,
in the middle of the night.
Yeah.
I still get mad about things like still,
let's talk about this again.
What's the date and someone else.
You're like,
all right.
Yeah.
You're someone else's problem.
Now the best is when they have a kid with someone else.
You're like,
yes,
it's over baby.
Yeah.
I've never talked to you again.
I'm free.
Yeah.
It's interesting.
Then it's,
it's a,
it's an interesting thing when you decide to touch naked bodies with the person.
Right.
Did he like it would create this bond by doing things with your bodies and
spending time together and then you separate,
but you're always going to have this,
Yay.
But I used to touch naked bodies with her,
you know?
Yeah.
We used to get together and we used to do things together.
We don't do it anymore,
but I did it.
I did it back in the day.
I got her naked and
we got naked together.
The history.
Yeah.
It's history.
It's weird,
you know?
Yeah.
She'll never forget.
I won't either.
We touched each other.
Yeah.
I liked the idea of like relationships.
Looking back fondly on relationships.
I never felt like I wasted my time.
The people that I've dated that I'm like probably shouldn't have done that.
But,
uh,
but for the most part I try to,
have good feelings about it.
You don't wanna,
you don't wanna hate like a period of your life now.
It's pointless.
But there's lessons learned.
Those ones that I've had that were like,
Ugh,
that's how,
you know what,
when you date someone and it's cool when they're,
they're good.
You got it.
Like I dated this girl long,
long time ago who's super negative
per negative all the time.
And then I dated this other girl right afterwards who was not negative at all.
She was always laughing about stuff and joking around.
No matter what.
Like even if it like a car get in an accident,
she'd take a deep breath and go,
wow,
that car's fucked up.
And she would start laughing and I was like,
oh,
this,
there's different ways to handle things.
Like if you get stuck with your high school sweetheart and,
and,
and she's a pain in the ass forever,
uh,
you never understand.
Like there are the exact same circumstances.
One person is going to handle it completely differently.
And if you're with that person,
it's going to be a totally different experience where it'll be a bonding
experience versus them woe is meaning for the next six months and bringing it
back to,
I can't even look at a tourist cause it reminds me of when I got in that
accident.
Tourists,
well I fucked those a year ago.
I like when people are together for a long time.
They break up and then the guy gets married to the next woman he runs into
instantly,
instantly.
It's like he just like found the opposite of what he'd been dealing with and was
just like so over the moon about it.
They had to marry right away.
Then I'm an old buddy of mine,
he did an actress and then it was just,
uh,
you know,
it was just brutal.
Everything was career,
this career that it was about her career was trying to help her career and,
and that they broke up and he's like,
I'm never getting married again.
A month later he's with this new check and he's living with her two months later
and then he's married six months later.
I'm like,
what happened?
He goes,
I realize it wasn't that I didn't want to be married.
I just didn't want to be married to her because I realized like there's some
people out there that I get along great with.
Yeah.
And if you don't,
if you don't bail on a bad relationship,
you don't know that there's you can be and you are going to be different.
That's the other thing like your d I'm different with different people.
You're different with like you react better to certain people and certain
people's personalities,
you jive better with them,
you have more fun with them.
It's more entertaining
and you get to like reintroduce yourself.
You know the other person knows you for this like five year period of time when
you,
and maybe you weren't at your best,
you know,
and like when you've already used all your tricks.
Yeah.
You know what I mean?
Like if you give a girl diamond earrings,
you can never give her diamond earrings again for as long as you live.
You know what I mean?
It's like that the president is over for now and then when you get a spoon with
someone new,
you can,
you know it's a clean slate,
right?
You can impress them.
Yeah.
They haven't heard your fucking dumb stories.
I'm gonna know that you can,
like,
you can pick all listen to this.
Why I always tell guys,
strive to be the person you pretend to be when you're trying to get laid.
If you can be that person,
that real person all the time,
but this is very difficult to do.
But if you can be that person most of the time,
if not all the time,
you'll have a better life.
Yes,
I would agree with that.
Yeah.
But it's fun to try to impress people.
It's fun when he meet someone,
I'm like,
boy,
wait til they see how witty I am.
Yeah.
It's weird.
Like with me,
I'm like,
I don't like when someone's just into me just because they know who I am.
If you're a famous comedian,
I'm like a little annoyed,
but if they have no idea who I am,
I'm also a little annoyed,
you know?
It's like,
there should be purpose to this that I'm missing out on it.
Did you not Google me?
Yeah.
He's not a comedy fan was from another country.
What's going on?
Can you imagine dating someone who didn't like comedy?
Anthony,
I love you.
You're amazing.
But I don't like stand up.
I mean,
if it was someone who just like didn't like stand up but thought I was great,
I could handle it.
They didn't like standup in general,
but they like your material in particular.
Do you watch a lot of standup?
Me?
Yeah.
I watch it at the clubs.
I very rarely sit down and watch a special.
Yeah,
it's true.
Do you watch the special ever a case?
Like right now I'm working on it and trying to put together a new album or,
so I'm trying to go back and watch stuff,
but for years I didn't watch anything.
Um,
uh,
but like,
it's funny,
like the three comics that I watch are you deleah and I'm Sebastian because I
follow you guys at the store.
So it's like I,
I'm in the room sitting there and you're the only three that I watch.
Like I could like for her,
I could like recite your act word for word and I don't watch anyone else.
It's so funny to me.
Well I think it's great to be,
again at a place like the store where you can see all these different styles and
all these different people doing it.
And you also see how we kind of influenced each other in the slightest bit.
And you know that we're all working in these really hot rooms where it's all
packed and,
but I think it's good to sit down and watch.
You know,
John Malaney when he did his world,
was that,
where was his radio city?
A city or you know,
Dave Chappelle,
wherever he did his,
he did his and DC I think.
Right?
The big one,
wasn't it in DC?
I the last one,
I think it was in la.
The last one.
Well he did the store with the belly room with the little one.
Oh,
the room.
He did another one where he's wearing like the military shirt with the CRM,
the Oj thing.
We talked about Oj that was in la and then there was one in Austin.
They may have been one more in DC.
I thought the most recent bigger one was in DC.
But either way the um,
maybe you're right where,
what?
Well Jamie,
we'll find it,
but it's,
I think it's,
uh,
it's good to see,
you know,
it's good to see how different people do it.
I always enjoy watching Katt Williams,
particularly in the beginning because you know,
like a lot of times he'll just out on stage and like he's running around on
stage for like five or 10 minutes before the fucking first Joe comes out and
he's pointing at people the audience and sweat and,
and going crazy.
It's,
and it's so different than the way anybody that I know does it.
It's good to see that too.
Yeah.
He,
I think the most discussed a standup special of the past year.
It was not in a net.
It was Kat Williams.
His,
did you see it?
Yes.
The one he did from Florida where he opens up at 10 minutes of Florida material,
15 minutes of Jacksonville material.
But it's like apparently destroying that we did.
I just,
I couldn't get enough of it.
We watched watched it a hundred times.
Yeah,
but it tapered off pretty hard.
Oh yeah.
Yeah.
I tapered off real hard when he was doing it.
The Trump stuff,
it's like,
wow,
this stuff is like half baked.
Yeah.
It looked like it looked like he had a bit to that they like made him cut and so
we had to just like do the hour anyway.
That's what I assume from having watched it.
That's how they do that though.
They don't tell you to do shit.
They don't tell me to do shit.
I don't think they're going to tell him to do shit.
They may have been like,
this is someone,
this is already a bit,
do you know what I mean?
As simple as that.
I don't know.
It seemed to me that it was almost like he had some shit to say but maybe hadn't
been doing a lot of stand up,
you know,
like I don't know how much that guy works out.
I don't see him anywhere.
No.
I always wonder about those guys.
Like the guys who you don't see in the clubs,
you know,
like bill,
Bill Bird saw a special one day,
um,
and uh,
we were doing a set together at the Ice House and uh,
he came into the green room,
like frothing at the mouth and then he's like,
he goes,
the,
the fucking guy,
I forgot.
Oh,
I know who he's talking about.
I'll tell you later.
But he was like,
the fucking guy doesn't do the clubs anymore.
He doesn't do the clubs.
He goes,
is watching this cringy bullshit.
And he was,
he was like angry and I was like,
you've got to do the fucking clubs.
Yeah.
People get too comfortable,
you know,
it's just,
it,
it's only their fans.
There's preaching to the fan base and they got like,
Bill Maher is not changing anyone's mind.
Just like people are,
people are applauding their,
that they know they're gonna apply before they even get there.
I would never do a comedy club.
He goes into comedy clubs at all.
No,
I'm sure he does not.
Yeah.
I think you,
I think you really have to.
Yeah,
no,
I think so too.
Yeah.
Well,
he's in this weird category too,
right?
Where he's not just doing in comedy,
he's got to do,
everything has to be political because this whole thing is about political,
political shit.
Like his show,
his,
his persona,
who he is,
you know,
he donated $1 million to the Democratic Party.
Like he's,
it's all politics.
Oh,
all of it.
And I can't stand political humor just because it's just,
it's so easy.
You know,
you're either,
you're either making everyone mad or you're making everyone really happy,
but it doesn't really matter like what the joke is.
Yeah.
You know?
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
It's,
uh,
and then if you're doing stuff about like the speaker of the house and you're
like,
oh my God,
it's when someone's like,
so the Mueller report,
it's like,
fuck man.
Like,
no,
you know,
who's like super deep into politics on the right is nick depaulo like every time
I talk to him.
Yeah.
And what's the talk about the fucking Steele dossier.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
Let's talk about all this different,
all the Shit Obama did.
Wow.
How about when Obama did this?
Well,
yeah.
How do you know?
Yeah,
I don't even know this.
I know the,
the,
the knowledge of it.
Like I once got a phone call,
like before the last election,
I get,
you know,
get a year ago.
And they're like,
we want to ask you about like,
how involved would you say are you with politics?
And I'm like,
very action.
I'm pretty passionate right now.
Um,
and like how,
how informed would you say you,
I'm like,
I'm,
I'm attempt,
very informed.
And they're like,
okay.
And they start asking me questions and I did not know what the fuck they were
talking about.
Like I hadn't heard of any of these things.
Any of these bills.
Like I have no idea.
I have no idea what's going on.
It's like the difference between a casual sports fan and someone who really
understands all the drafts and all the pics from different colleges and all with
this guy's got potential and this guy needs to work on this defense.
This is a 40 times.
Yeah.
Yes.
The people who know the combined numbers.
Yeah.
He bench pressed two 24 or 47 times.
Just people that know that stuff.
It's exhausting because it,
it,
it's so involved.
Like you have to,
if you really want to be paying attention to everything that's going on with
Nancy Pelosi,
you know,
you gotta,
you gotta be paying attention to that all day long.
And most of the people that do that,
they're nuts.
Like you're,
you're,
it's just,
it's like sports.
It's sports,
but in a different way.
Like you're just there.
This is the thing that you're wrapped up in [inaudible] although it does shape
our world,
you know?
Yeah.
As a,
as like right wing comics go though does not a lot.
I'm like Nick Dipaolo is that king because he's actually really fucking funny.
Like he's right wing as like a person and you know,
he's conservative but he's also a great standup comedian.
But did he get more right?
Yes.
As he got older.
Yeah.
So it wasn't all always,
cause I remember Depaulo he's one of my favorites.
Uh,
you know,
when I would see him on TV as a kid and I know I'm a little bit now,
but uh,
the,
the right thing seem to come up more and more in the past 10 years.
Yeah.
He was always an angry guy,
but he became like an old angry guy that's really into politics as he got older.
Yeah.
I mean I guess part of it is like,
it works for him.
Like it's,
people love to hear it.
Like there's not a lot of those guys,
like who is the right have to bank on in terms of like comics that they could go
see Tim Allen barely.
Does he do standup anymore?
I think he does.
Like,
I think it goes up to the laugh factory.
Does it?
Yeah.
Okay.
So maybe he's one of those guys that like when was the last time you want to say
six months ago,
you know what I mean?
Oh yeah.
You know what I mean?
I don't,
I don't know,
maybe I'm wrong,
but who else?
Okay,
so you got Tim Allen and Nick Depaulo.
It's gotta be more,
there must be,
I mean Norton kind of leans right a little bit more libertarian,
but he doesn't do a lot of politic jokes.
He'll talk about it.
But what the fuck else is like no one.
But if you wanted it like left wing comedians so you could start with Michelle
Wolf and work your way up.
Oh yeah,
there's,
there's millions of them.
Michelle Wolf wasn't even like left wing.
I think the correspondents' dinner,
everyone's like,
this is a star making turn.
And I think it almost ruined her.
Really?
Like,
yes,
because her show Netflix was called the break.
Like it was called the break and was like,
we're going to take a break from all of this and just talk about like other
things going on in the world.
We don't need to be focused on politics.
And after that,
after the correspondence dinner,
it was like Dee opening show was like her going after Sarah Huckabee Sanders and
you're like,
oh,
you,
you got forced into this niche.
Yeah.
It's tricky if you find a thing that like works and then people like you should
really concentrate on that.
Like I remember Jamie Masada gave her a friend of mine,
uh,
advice once way back in the day.
He's like,
you should be generation x guy when you go onstage or should be,
I'm from generation x any time,
you know,
like my generation generation x think this and talk like that.
But he was giving him advice and I was like,
listen to me,
don't listen to that.
Has Jimmy massage ever given good advice?
I don't know.
As Tiffany Haddish,
she's still mad.
He manages it.
Right.
So He's,
he's doing something right.
He's manages,
sir.
Yeah.
Like recently I actually fired everybody.
Maybe she fired him too.
Yeah.
I don't know.
She's a wild woman.
She can do whatever the fuck she wants now,
you know?
But you know,
I'm so happy for her.
I knew her when the shit wasn't going well.
You know?
She's always been wild though.
She's a wild person,
she seems like.
Yeah.
In a good way.
Like Hey.
Yeah,
just one of the two people that I saw like onstage was like,
oh,
you're going to be a star.
Like I didn't know anything about her,
but I was just like,
you just start.
Was it when she was creeping into the microphone?
No.
No,
it was not that you ever seen her do that?
No.
Dude,
she can make the most ungodly sounds with her vagina.
Like for real?
Yeah.
Oh yeah.
She takes the microphone.
She puts it on her pussy and goes like she knows how to do it.
She has,
apparently she has an ability to make a noise with a vagina on cue thing.
Actually,
I did go before her.
If I had to follow that,
I'd be fear in front of six people.
Can I get a new mic?
Yeah.
I followed her before.
I didn't even think about it.
I probably should have.
Yeah,
I figured like the genes or filter enough.
Yeah.
You hope so.
Yeah,
we'd hope.
Yeah.
It's still,
it's not ideal.
You like that type of personally thought wild personality that like a Gallach
has that has like,
what the fuck else could she have done other than stand up.
I Dunno,
but there's a lot of those people out there that never find stand up.
Oh Shit.
Then life just becomes chaos.
Like the crazy person at the office,
you know,
it's just stuck there and the,
you get fired from enough of those jobs where you can't even get that office job
anymore because
you know the word gets out.
Oh yeah.
Don't hire Tiffany.
That crazy bitch.
She's never going to be there.
And when she is there,
she's going to Queef into the fucking loud speaker.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
Wish.
I mean,
part of me says no,
I don't wish that there was like some sort of an organized program to get into
comedy because figuring it out,
I figured it out.
You figured it out.
All of us did.
But then part of me says,
man,
there's so many kids out there,
there's probably a 16 year old kid right now who sees the hypocrisy in all the
things that these adults are doing.
And He fucking hates class.
And he's sitting there right now going nuts.
Or there's a girl who's feeling the same way about our stupid friends and her
mom and all these fucking people that want her to be a certain way.
And she's like,
Jesus Christ,
I gotta get the fuck away from these people.
And,
and she makes her friends laugh,
but nobody ever tells her,
hey listen to me.
You could do this.
You could talk shit about things.
Like you could be a really funny comedian.
Like you've got to figure out a way to do that.
Nobody does that.
Like you,
you,
it's so it,
the,
the number of people that have the,
like how many people have you ever met in your life that have the potential to
be a comic but never did it?
Like when you're around them,
you're like,
damn,
this guy is funny.
Cause I'm gonna comment
five or six,
you know,
there are people who are like as funny as me in college who just went on and got
jobs and I got funnier.
You know,
like I knew people like that are people.
One of the funniest guys I've ever met in my life was like a,
was like an executive producers Pa,
but he was so goddamn funny.
I couldn't believe it.
But he like,
I don't think it would have translated to the stage.
There's something like,
there's something you have to figure out in yourself to become a good community.
And if you're the funniest guy in the world,
yes.
You know,
it's a different,
it's a different muscle,
you know?
Yeah.
But I,
and I like that there's so many different ways to do it.
Like I started in La and people like,
you should not start in la.
Yeah,
Ari did too.
I think it helped me because it was like you had to get good right away.
Well,
Ari,
Ari did open mikes in DC at first,
but then basically started out in la when I met him.
He was a doorman at the comedy store in or just a raw open miker yeah,
it's hard to,
it's hard to start out in la,
but it can be done.
Especially now,
especially,
we don't know any better,
you know,
like I,
I didn't,
I found out like years after I'd started in La that you should not start in la.
Yeah.
And it wasn't like I was going to move and go.
I was already living here when I decided to do stand up,
but I wasn't going to like move to Chicago,
uh,
and start there.
Yeah.
Some people do and they know it doesn't seem to work.
No.
I don't know anybody who's ever moved from La to like a satellite community like
Denver or somewhere like that,
unless they were already really established.
I don't know anybody who was starting out who moved somewhere where it worked
out well,
no,
they always,
they come back or like to go to Austin.
I'm like,
I'm going to try it out there.
And it's like,
it doesn't,
you're just starting over.
Yeah.
You got to start there.
There's,
yeah,
there's no right or wrong way to do it,
but man,
it would be nice if somebody sort of collected thoughts on how like what to do
and what not to do.
Yeah.
Like some people are like,
oh,
you got to get in the road.
Just get on the road and like,
and it's like,
no,
that's,
that's not great advice.
If you're doing see rooms,
it just going to make you hate the road.
Right.
I've seen people who just look like worn through that.
Like they're just like every night they're going up and they're either like,
I have to be like a crowd pleaser because the person's just coming to see
comedy.
Like I'm so lucky people come to see Anthony Jeselnik and not just a comedy show
because that's,
that can be brutal and painful and a lot of people who were like,
no,
just get in the road and then their act suffers.
They had this like hackey act all the sudden because they had to do it like
that.
He would kiss me like serious anxiety when I find out that someone got a Vegas
residency,
I go,
how many nights a week?
Six,
six nights a week at the stratosphere.
It sounds,
I mean,
someone told me David spade was thinking about doing one and he went to go see
Louis Anderson who was doing one this before baskets and he was like,
it was just the saddest thing I've ever seen.
That was a Carlin's last stand was a Vegas residency.
Did he have a Vegas residency?
Yeah.
Where was he at?
I forget where he was,
but he had like a meltdown where he like went off on the crowd,
just like talk to calling them all pieces of shit.
Really.
And Yeah.
And then had to go to rehab was like,
I'm,
I'm addicted to painkillers like,
and an unlucky ever.
I don't if he ever performed again.
Well,
he died before he died.
He was performing when he died.
I mean,
I think he was at a hotel,
I'm pretty sure he was sleeping in a hotel,
that he was performing it when he died.
I would believe that,
but I didn't because I had done that last special he did was terrible.
Where he's like reading half of it.
Oh,
I didn't see that.
It was,
it was,
it was just like a,
you know,
a swan song for him.
But I think that was after the Vegas residency.
So must have been doing more.
Yeah,
his schedule was very,
very hectic and unusual.
He was doing one hour a year,
an hour specialty would film and he would write it all out.
Like he would write it all out and then tweak it a little bit.
But it was more of a monologue than it was like set up punchline jokes.
And he seemed to be,
he was falling into this more like a sort of more of a social commentator in
some aspects than he was a standup towards the end.
You know what I mean?
Oh yeah.
Someone told me that he,
a lot of the reason he did an hour every year was because a,
it like tax problems and the IRS has come out of hard.
And,
uh,
so we had to be working that much and it kind of made a miserable,
you know the story about his nine 11 story,
right.
Um,
tell me where he recorded a special called.
I kind of like it when a lot of people die.
That was the name of the special and he has this whole closes with a big long 20
minute thing about like when he hears about people dying,
he'd,
the more the better.
And he filmed it on like September 10th,
and then the next day came in and was like,
we've got,
we've got to cancel this,
but no one can ever see this or hear this and now you can get the album.
But even in the album he's reading it,
they like it.
They destroyed the actual footage from the taping.
Oh really?
Yeah.
They destroyed it.
Oh,
he was just like,
there's no one can ever see this.
Wow.
Recorded in Vegas at the MGM Grand on September 9th and 10th.
September 9th and 10th.
That's crazy.
Yeah.
What was it called?
I kind of like him.
A lot of people die.
Jesus Christ.
He must've woken up the morning of September 11th and going,
did I manifest this?
Yeah,
look at that.
I kind of like it when a lot of people die.
And so the audio CD,
it's just him talking.
It's like him working out the,
uh,
wait a minute.
It says streaming audio streaming with Amazon prime's so there's no video of it
on,
I'll look to see if there is some,
some person who works somewhere might have preserved it.
I mean,
I feel like I would've heard about it.
like I said,
I listened to the bit and it's,
if he's like,
I've got to read this,
this is how I do it.
So it's like a very early version of it.
But,
uh,
it's not great.
But I mean,
I can't,
I can't even imagine taping a special on September 10th he had some dark moments
in his career.
I took some friends to see him in 1988 at the Hampton Beach Casino.
I think that's what it was called in Hampton Beach,
New Hampshire.
It was like a place where people would go up for vacation and we went to see a
George Carlin there way back in the day and he always had the same opening act
and the same opening.
I kind of knew even back then cause I was,
I guess I was an open miker then I was just starting out.
Um,
I knew there were certain guys,
he took people on the road with them that were terrible that they took people on
the road with him that just didn't,
they weren't good comics,
but they made them look like heroes and they did it because they were friends
with them or because they just wanted to have like the worst comic ever go up
before that.
It's a good question.
You know,
you'd have to,
I guess it would vary,
but for sure there's certain comics that like it when people go on in front of
them suck.
They do,
they,
they want that.
You know,
there's certain comics that you see them taking people on the road and you look
at it,
you're like,
what the fuck?
You're taking that guy with you?
Like,
what are you doing?
Why,
why are you torturing people like that?
Yeah.
But,
uh,
the opening acted better than George.
He had terrible set.
He had this whole rant that he was doing,
cause he was like,
he had an unquestionably one of the greatest comics of all time,
but he had hours that were just not good.
And there was a period of time where it seemed like he just missed it.
Like it was like it was missing whether it was his personal life was off or
whatever it was.
But he had this whole rant that was like,
fuck this.
And he was like,
and fuck Israel and fuck comedy clubs.
Like he was saying,
fuck comedy clubs.
Like this is like this whole bit.
And he was reading it off of
a yellow legal pad and the whore is like standing there like not understanding
like where this was going.
Like we're waiting for the jokes,
where's the hilarity?
Whereas the,
and it wasn't,
it just didn't exist.
And my friends were mad at me,
how can I take it?
I had taken them from where we live.
We lived in revere and we all drove all the way up to New Hampshire.
Like,
yeah,
we're going to go see George Collins is going to be awesome.
And it was terrible.
It's funny,
I remember Louis C K and like an interview years ago was talking about how he
took the pressure,
came off of him to always have a good show.
But you said audience members love sang.
I saw George Carlin once and he was awesome.
But they really love saying,
you know,
I saw Carlin once and he was horrible.
Like they,
they still get the experience and the story of it and that it's theirs forever.
I don't have to worry about doing a bad,
it's better though.
If they say you were funny.
I think it's,
I think to see a legend bomb would be,
uh,
would be great.
Well,
if you are a and fan,
you got to see those.
If you went to see him live a bunch of times,
yeah,
he had those rough spots,
man.
You know,
it's,
um,
it's one of those things,
if you're going to do an hour of standup every year,
you can have some rough ones.
There's just no way around that.
Oh,
100%.
It seems like that's just,
I mean it can be done.
I think it can be done.
I mean,
I think you can put together like I'm six months in from my last special,
I think I could do another special in six months,
but it wouldn't be as good as my last one,
I don't think.
Yeah,
I just don't think it would,
I just think you need time.
Yeah.
One a year.
It's crazy.
One of yours.
It's insane.
Like the,
the guys like Jimmy Carr who while they're touring,
they're writing jokes and just putting them away.
So at the end of the tour,
when they taped the special,
they have all these jokes they can go through and look at and then start the new
tour from that.
That seems like I like to sit in my set,
you know what I mean?
I just want to be focused on that and not always be writing the next thing,
but some people who were just like,
I'm just going to go up and talk and then see it happening a lot now.
I think with like the prevalence of Netflix specials,
people just want the money and they're famous enough they can just go up and
just get through it.
I'm like,
this is your legacy.
Like why would you want to put out a bad special ever?
I don't care what they're paying you make sure it's great
the same way and I feel like those people that watched that,
when you do do that,
man,
if you don't acknowledge that you fucked them over,
they're never going to trust you again.
If you don't say,
hey look,
that one wasn't a good special.
I gave it a shot.
It just wasn't right.
It didn't come out right.
I thought it was pretty good and then the taping didn't go well and if you don't
do that,
they're not going to listen to you man.
They were like,
this is my best work.
Like this is,
Oh,
this is your best work.
Yeah,
well the fuck
you can like fold them once.
And I mean like if I want,
if I went on tour right now and just did the same material from the special,
like people would be like,
okay,
but they're not coming back the next time.
You know they're gonna get mad at you.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
When you do a special,
once it's on Netflix,
you're done with that material,
it's over done.
I think people don't,
I try not even to remember it.
Like I'm an idiot in the way that I teach.
I like assumed that the entire audience has seen everything I've ever done good.
Like I really do think that.
And it's like,
even if it's one guy in the back of was like,
I've heard these before,
no one else has heard it.
It's still drives me crazy that I can't,
I don't know.
It's,
I've got too much pride.
I have the same feeling and I'll say sometimes too.
And here's like if something comes up,
I go,
I have an old bid on this and I'll say the bit,
but I'll let them know this is an old bit like this.
This is,
you know,
I got this old bit.
Yeah.
Some books.
Some people though,
they,
when someone comes to see you,
like Jim Gaffigan,
they want,
if they don't see hot pockets,
oh they get fucking mad.
I saw Gaffigan and Toronto a couple of years ago and he did killer hour,
just walks out,
does the hour,
says thank you,
good night walks off stage,
walks right back on and does hot pockets.
Doesn't ask who wants to your hot pockets.
Just goes right into it.
Does the whole 10 minute thing and then says good night and walks off stage.
Well,
Burke crises that way with the machine,
like he has to tell that fucking story.
Yeah.
Even though people see it,
they want to see it live.
Yeah.
He's trapped.
And maybe if I had more stories I could get away with it.
But once you hear the joke,
you know it's,
it's over.
It doesn't,
it doesn't work again.
Yeah.
Seinfeld still does,
old,
old stuff,
does really old stuff and he's done two specials of old stuff that he's like,
he's already put on specials.
I went and saw him at the palladium,
uh,
about a year or two ago and it was one of the worst shows I've ever seen.
Like I had like a splitting headache and I was like furious really.
And one of my friends in another comic that I respect a lot gave him a standing
ovation and I was like,
are you fucking kidding me?
And he was like,
I understand why you feel the way you do,
but I just love seeing the act.
And I was like,
I couldn't believe it.
And then I saw Seinfeld again at cluster fest.
He was in the big outdoor stage with a bunch of like for kids completely
different hour and murdered like destroyed.
Then it was like,
he has like corny stuff depending on what the audience,
you know,
is if everyone's sitting there wearing a Yamaka,
he's got one act and if it's a bunch of kids he's got and he's got a cool hip
act.
Really?
Yeah.
So you went to the Amika crowd?
Interesting.
What was bad about that?
It was a aggressively corny and just really corny is a funny phrase.
A good like you would like.
Thank you for coming to the show.
I know,
you know,
we were like,
should we go to the show?
Should we go?
Should we go to the shows we get?
Did we nuber throughout?
How did we get to the show?
Do we really want to get it down?
I'm like,
I can't believe he's doing this right now.
But people were eating it up.
Like everyone around me was going nuts and loving it.
Uh,
but it was just like old man corny.
Oh Man.
Could you see Seinfeld on like a talk show?
And
he's like mean kind of biting and you're like,
oh,
this is great.
Like,
he's hilarious.
And I expected more of that,
but when I saw him cluster fest,
I got that.
You know what his cluster fest,
it's uh,
it's,
uh,
it's the third year.
This year.
The festival in San Francisco.
It's a comedy central and Coachella together put together a thing.
It's all comedy,
a comedy,
music,
listen,
music teacher,
whenever I see festivals,
I was assume someone's getting ripped off.
That's what I think my,
my impression is or who's getting the money,
who's,
who's getting the money out of this.
That's how I feel about like Montreal.
But there's the occasional no big a festival.
You're like,
okay this much for for like one show in Toronto.
Like yeah,
I'm totally in.
I'm totally,
so sometimes it's great and sometimes it's nothing.
Yeah,
the just for laughs thing.
My issue with that is I got in when I was a zero.
Like I got an adjustable apps when I was four years into comedy.
I think five,
I was terrible.
You know,
I had like a 10 minute set that I could do and it could get some laughs,
but I became a part of just for laughs.
Like when it was helping me,
I wasn't helping it.
But then when I see festivals where I see like a lot of names on a thing and I'm
like,
well,
who's funding this?
Like sponsored by southwest airlines.
So like,
well what is this weird corporate mishmash that you've put together and who's
profiting off of this?
Like it's not the comedians.
Like I get why you put it all together,
but then you find out how much,
how much the comedians are getting like well where's the rest of the money
going?
There's a lot of money in that audience is a big place.
Yeah.
You know,
just some are better than others,
but like,
and sometimes they're just like,
we're going to take a loss of,
the sponsors are going to lose money on this,
but we're going to like that riot fest in La,
they would do every year.
It's done now.
But did it like four or five years in a row and it never made money.
It was a comedy festival in downtown La.
Really?
Yeah.
See that's how much I,
I haven't version of those things.
I don't even know when they're taking place cause I say no to everything.
I'm like,
no,
you're not just priced out of it.
No.
It's like people are like,
oh I don't,
I haven't done the college in years.
And it's not like I've got a problem with colleges.
It's just like they can't afford,
well I stopped doing colleges when they could afford me cause I just would just,
I'd be performing in front of 18 year olds.
I'd be like,
this is ridiculous.
I just like,
there's too many of them that don't have life experience.
They're,
they're growing minds and you can make them laugh at some things but they
haven't experienced what I like.
It's like I'm happily married but if I wasn't,
I'd like a chick was a little bitter.
I like a older chick.
Keeps yourself fit.
These experienced a lot in life.
Who understands?
She understands that life is up and down.
There's hardships.
I'm not interested in anyone who's young and delusional and bubbly.
Yeah,
no.
So that when you go to perform in front of 18 year olds,
like they have this like this delusional version of what the world should be and
social justice and all these ideas about the economy and all these ideas about
socialism and all these ideas.
I don't like,
I'm exhausted already.
I can't,
I can't do this.
I still think it's fun.
I think it's fun to watch them just be like,
Holy Shit,
you don't have to do one show.
You know what I mean?
Maybe they can leave if they want.
I don't feel any pressure.
I mean casinos more than more than,
uh,
colleges.
But I loved like even if one bad,
it was an interesting bat and you're,
and you're getting paid so much money that you're like,
I don't care.
I don't care how this goes.
And I've,
I've had some go real,
I used to go to the college and say,
uh,
what should I not talk about?
And then whatever they said I would open with that and it,
and it worked every time.
Except Colorado School of mines.
What does that,
the Colorado School of mines is like a um,
it's a engineering school.
Yeah,
School of mines.
Mines.
Yeah.
It's a famous m I.
N e or m.
Like digging.
I thought you were saying mine's too.
I was with Joe
and I,
they said do not talk about abortion.
And I was like,
okay.
And I went up and open wounds and abortion joke and then died for an hour.
Like they never forgave me.
I just completely ate shit.
Was it a good abortion joke?
I assume
to have it a bad abortion joke is like if you're going to tell I have a joke
about abortion and better be great,
you know,
or you're a or you're in some real trouble where there are those people that
think that when you touch on controversial subjects that there's like a little,
there's weight to objects,
right?
Like there's certain things that have more weight to them.
Like if you can get through,
if you can actually get the bit to work,
it will have like a,
an artificial amount of momentum connected to it because of the fact that it was
all this weight.
It's more tension.
Yeah.
If you can cut that tension,
the laugh is bigger.
Yeah,
sure.
Yeah.
But if you can't,
oh no,
it's over.
Yeah.
They just like Maddie for even trying.
You know,
I don't think people get mad really,
that people make jokes about awful things.
They get mad at the idea that people think it's funny.
Yeah.
You know,
it's not so much you've told a cancer joke.
It's like you think cancer is funny.
It's like,
no I don't.
That's why I'm making a joke about it.
You know?
That's like,
that's,
that's the process.
But I really think it's like,
it's hearing an audience laugh at it more than hearing a comic.
Like if a comic tells it a cancer joke in a bombs,
no one really gets mad at them.
If it's like killing,
that's when people get upset.
Well,
you act is so controversial.
You have so many subjects and it's so much tongue in cheek and there's so much
where you're,
you know,
you,
you say mean shit on stage.
I would imagine that you get people upset at you quite a bit.
I used to and honestly now it's like I've been like grandfathered in and like,
it's funny,
like I used to get people,
I would tweet a joke and some people would the comments and people were getting
mad at me and now what happens is that tweeted joke and then my fans start
tweeting their own jokes underneath it,
like tagging and people get mad at them.
It's like I'm just like the guy who is allowed to do it and people would stop
getting mad
at me.
All of a sudden you had a show called the Jessel neck offensive.
I mean you've,
you do,
you are sort of grandfathered in,
but it's also like your style.
Yeah.
It's like,
it's like being mad at slayer for being loud.
Like what do you,
that's what they do.
Exactly.
What are you talking about?
Yeah.
You're like,
but I like classical music.
It's like,
so what?
Go listen to that.
Yeah.
That is the weird thing about comedy too,
right?
It's like when you go to see comedy,
you could see all sorts of different styles.
Whereas when you go to see music,
if you go to a club,
it's like a blues club.
You expect to see blues.
Like you're going there on purpose.
You don't,
it's not like a blues band followed by a country band fall by a hardcore band
like it doesn't,
but that's what you get when you go to a comedy club.
You can get guns and roses followed by Barry Manilow and you're like,
what is this place?
Yeah.
You know,
like a,
a main room show on a Saturday night,
you're going to get virtually every genre of comedy there is.
I mean,
I liked that.
I'm glad it's like that because I hate,
like I when I used to tour and I couldn't bring my own opener,
you know,
I would get to town,
they're like,
oh,
Jake has been begging us to open to open views so badly for months.
So we're letting him open a for you.
And he does my act for 15 minutes before he brings me onstage.
I was like,
I hate this and see if you haven't asked someone to actually do your actual
material.
Not my material,
but like they'll,
my mannerisms,
you know,
short,
dark jokes,
you know,
like that my attitude,
they've just like taken it and they're like,
Oh,
if he,
Anthony sees me,
he'll be like,
oh,
you're like me,
come do that.
I'm like,
I don't want to see me.
You know,
I want to see anyone like me.
I don't ever,
I don't want us to like,
someone's like,
all this guy does really dark one liners.
You'd love it.
I'm like,
don't ever want to see it.
I don't ever want to look at it because that's what I do.
Right.
You know,
I like,
I want to see goofy,
silly,
just like the opposite of me.
Yeah.
Joey Diaz likes to bring girls on stage.
He brought it likes to bring girls on the road with them because he said he
wants the audience to see something totally different.
Anyone to give the women in the audience that are with their boyfriends that are
there to see him.
Like,
he's like,
this is good.
Like it'll balance it out.
I bring a lot of female openers,
uh,
mostly just completely different.
I don't want the same.
Even like,
I don't want them talking about the same subjects as me,
you know,
and then that's you that usually avoids it.
Uh,
completely.
I don't know.
I don't know how much I'm doing it for the,
the girlfriends of the guys who have come and certainly,
you know,
there are people come afterwards and then I liked you better than the headline
or it's like,
it is weird when you start taking someone on the road with you and then their
acts or it's morphing and becoming like yours,
like their style source because they see what,
what's working and so they start,
it's like a natural thing.
Like,
like you saying that you can't watch tell anymore,
you know,
especially with someone who's opening for you,
you got to think they're in the developmental period.
Oh yeah.
I've had MCS who by the end of the weekend or like,
that's a great joke and I'm like,
Hey,
that's my line.
Like you can't,
I know it's fun to do,
but like you can't do it when you're opening from me.
Like you've just been watching me all weekend and now you're copying my manner
with that.
That's knowing.
Yeah.
Cause then you have to think
about it.
[inaudible]
well,
you have to watch them.
Is there any places where you just don't work anymore?
Like any cities?
We were like,
fuck this place.
Do you work in Miami and Miami?
I try not to.
I'll do it.
I'll do a feed or in Miami or like close by,
but I would never do a club down there.
Like Miami's like New Orleans and New Orleans is one of my favorite cities in
the world.
But like,
they have shit going on.
Yeah.
They don't care about your comedy.
Right.
You know,
Miami,
there's just too much else to do.
And New Orleans who've got like their music and their food and their alcohol,
they don't care about comedy.
Uh,
you can,
you can do a show there,
but it's not a,
it's not that fun.
It's not that fun.
Yeah.
Um,
Miami might be the one,
but I'll do like Fort Lauderdale,
you know,
places around that.
A Florida can be tough.
Miami adjacent.
Yeah.
It's hard.
It's tough.
Man.
Yeah,
it's tough.
That's it.
That is the weirdest fucking state in the country for sure.
Yeah.
I'm trying to think of any other place that I was just like their clubs.
I would never go back to,
what about Connecticut?
Connecticut?
I think I just did somewhere in Connecticut and had a great,
I had a great time.
I think they were just like,
they were like grateful that I was there.
I know some places you go and they're just like,
oh,
I can't believe he came here.
Yeah,
this is awesome.
Yeah.
But there was a,
I went to one club where just like the owner of the club made his,
made the green room.
His office.
Yeah.
And we'd just sit in there and like be watching TV and talking to me the entire,
I'm like,
surely you're going to leave with 20 minutes before I go on stage and just what,
just in your face the whole time.
Like that was why he owned the club was to talk to comics and I just like lost
my mind.
Where was this?
Um,
uh,
I probably shouldn't say,
but I won't say,
uh,
what it sound like.
Um,
Columbus,
Ohio,
I think through issues.
Think what?
Hoosier's Hoosiers,
what are the Indiana yeah,
next door.
Oh,
okay.
Yeah.
Okay.
Do you ever been there?
Um,
I think I did a show there once.
Yeah.
Coming up.
It was like a,
it was like a cool club to go do.
And I finally got there and like a year or so ago and I was like,
even on my friends,
I was like,
why did you,
why is everyone loved this club so much?
And they're like,
we couldn't wait to hear what you thought of him.
Wait to hear how mad you would get to this guy.
The weird thing is when a guy owns the club,
but then he's also the MC that happen.
Oh,
the worst.
The absolute worst.
Can't stamp that.
Yeah.
That's not good.
No.
Yeah.
Is there any places in a overseas that you really enjoy working?
I went on a big European tour this summer and did,
uh,
did the,
did the standards,
you know,
did a couple of nights in London,
a couple of nights in Edinburgh during the festival.
Those were fun.
Um,
and then like places off the beaten path that I was like,
I want to do Berlin and I want to do Warsaw.
And they were like,
there's no market.
And I'm like,
I to do those,
those are the two most fun shows of the whole tour.
And it was like 300 people maybe.
But uh,
but they were just so grateful you were there and they were,
they were awesome.
And they understand English like he would,
they,
they understand it better than they can speak it.
So they laugh at every joke.
Nothing goes over their heads.
They don't have to change any references.
I've really loved,
uh,
the European tour.
It was cool because if you do an a place to like 300 seats,
even if it's a primarily a German or Polish speaking country,
there's going to be enough people that speak English.
They can come to your show.
Yeah.
A lot of ex pats,
you know,
and they're like,
and they,
they all say they got comedy 10 years ago.
Youtube is what did it for them.
So they all had these standup comedy scenes that are all 10 years old and
they're all like dirt.
They're like bad for,
for people to do doing it.
10 years old,
there's still hacky,
you know,
they're like a generation away from,
from getting good bye amber in Warsaw.
They were like,
this is a historic day for Polish comedy.
Like you're the first American comic,
like big American comic to come here and do a show.
And now I think burrs go in there,
maybe just went there.
Uh,
but they're a,
they're getting more and more people wore saw what is Polen like honestly,
we like got into the airport.
Asar luggage was,
wasn't there,
went straight to the GIG,
went on stage,
uh,
when to the hotel and the next morning flew to Budapest.
Like we didn't get to see any of Warsaw or do anything there.
I was one of the cities.
It was just,
there was just nothing to do.
But when I had my old comedy central show,
the Jessel nick offensive,
someone at comedy central says,
listen,
we can look at Google and tell you where your googled all around the world.
America by far the most.
Canada close second and then Wa and then uh,
Poland is number three and I'm like pulling why?
And they go,
they think you're Polish,
Polish,
they think they assume you're Polish.
So I'm like,
let's book a show there and have all these people come out.
And whoever told me that fucking lied to me like they would,
they were like,
what?
We don't think your Polish?
Like why would you think your Polish?
Like,
no,
we don't give a shit.
I don't know who's told you that?
[inaudible] neck.
Slovenian.
Ah,
yeah.
Do you ever go there?
No.
Never been.
Never just do a show there.
It was,
it's kind of,
um,
I think I thought about it,
but it was just like routing,
you know what I mean?
It's like,
do I want to deal with what I have to deal with to get to Slovenia when I can
just go,
you know,
from to Australia at all.
Yeah.
I just did Australia.
I did like a,
I did a few weeks,
like a one week at the very end of the tour.
What'd you do?
I did a Brisbane,
Adelaide,
uh,
Melbourne and Sydney.
Melbourne and Sydney is the only places I've done,
but it's fucking a,
they're great.
I love those too.
Yeah.
If the world war three hits and that,
that place doesn't get nuked,
that's the spot you think so.
Yeah.
It's an,
the other side of the planet wasn't their book though.
We're like,
that happens and everyone goes to Australia,
but there's like a cloud of radiation coming that's eventually going to get
them.
Fuck.
Maybe we just get a big fan blow that shit to Russia.
I bet that would work.
But it's just the Chinese exam.
Look if they can figure out how to nuke an entire country with a few bombs that
drop out of airplanes or shoot out a rockets,
we should be able to build a giant fan.
Build a big fan.
Yeah.
Why is it so hard?
Like I was reading the shit about space junk.
Do you know how much space chunk there is?
Like this style's a lot floating around in space,
like thousands of pieces of shit just flying around broken satellites parts.
Is it all just broken satellites?
All kinds of shit.
All kinds of stuff.
Stuff from,
you know like when rockets take off and then they eject.
They leave little pieces of stuff up in there and it.
And is it like in a ring like let me take a Saturn type or ring or is it just
everywhere?
It's everywhere.
It's all over the planet.
It's like it's in the sky.
Like it's in the ocean.
It's like there's pieces of shit just flying around above our head and like they
have to be cognizant about it if they're going to launch a rocket.
Yeah,
like you could run into it.
Space,
debris and human spacecraft.
The all travel at speeds up to 17,500 miles an hour,
more than 500,000 pieces of debris or space junk are tracked as the orbit earth.
Think of that.
They travel at speeds up to 17,500 miles and hour small enough for a relatively
small piece of orbital debris to damage a satellite or a spacecraft.
That's,
how was that movie with Sandra Bullock?
Gravity.
Yeah.
Cause it doesn't.
Nice chunk comes down on us.
Yeah.
They're like fixing a satellite and someone comes by and hits them,
mix it and the next thing you know,
fuck that shit can happen and they don't know what to do either.
Like the throw a net up there.
What are you going to do?
I would think of like some kind of magnet satellite that would just attract
everything.
Right.
But then it would probably get too heavy.
I think we'll probably take out things that you need.
Yeah.
Is this the junk that we can track over time?
It starts at 57 there's only two things out there and that God word gross were
so gross.
I bet the ocean's a similar similar story.
Wow.
Look at all the shit around is even worse.
Oh my God.
That's incredible.
That's all real.
I don't know,
2015 the entire low enter like near Earth orbit is covered with shit,
space,
debris,
satellites and nonsense.
I mean at what point in time,
I mean we've only been traveling in the space since the 1960s right,
so what?
When is this going to end like that?
That's not that long ago.
That's 50 plus years ago.
What are we going to do when it's a hundred years from now?
500 Years from now?
I mean are we going to be able to see the sun?
Let me just look up and just see space shit floating overhead instead.
It's only 500,000 pieces of the earth is pretty fucking big still.
We'd have to get,
yeah,
I guess like I just snapped the fact that it said if you dug a hole through the
earth,
it would take you 42 minutes to fall through it.
It's like how fucking big as that.
So it's a long,
long drawl.
Yeah,
it's a long,
far Austin.
I was thinking would you stop in the middle?
It
dies.
It cooked.
I know,
but in theory if you didn't yet.
Yeah.
If it was just a tube,
an n zero temperature or neutral temperature tube.
I wonder how like how accurate Snapple facts really have to be like bull shit on
a Snapple fact,
like don't drink that shit.
So I don't read those things.
I didn't even know they had Snapple facts until you just said that.
I didn't.
They used to have like little things on the caps.
Like you say,
it makes sense to me,
but I don't think I've ever read one of them.
I used to always read them.
No.
Yeah,
I can't remember any of them ever get angry.
How does snap effect?
No,
I have gotten mad at like a Bazooka Joe Comic.
Just be like this fucking you kidding me?
Yeah,
this is bullshit.
They phone it in sometimes big time.
Well,
comics in general I think is some,
like,
there's great comics,
there's really funny comics,
but then there's comic strips that have existed forever and they're fucking
terrible.
And for some reason or another they just still exist.
Oh yeah.
Do they any more though?
Like is there still a sec?
I haven't read a newspaper.
Like a physical print?
No,
I think it's smaller and smaller.
Uh,
the than it ever has been before.
But like,
they're still cranking out Garfield,
you know?
Garfield's still a thing.
Yeah.
And the guy,
Jim Davis,
critic Garfield has nothing to do with it.
He's like golfing and like collecting money and he's got ghost writers.
So it was just like the worst shit ever.
Oh Wow.
So he hires people to do it and he makes all the money.
He's probably worth $1 billion.
I guarantee the merchandise,
this fucking things.
You stick on your car alone.
My bad.
Those were everywhere that like the,
yeah,
it's all so I think the Calvin and Hobbes guy would never let them make toys of
Calvin and Hobbes and the books.
Yeah.
He didn't want that money.
A Calvin and Hobbes plug money once.
He didn't want his creation being like,
he didn't want to be like Jim Davis.
Um,
that's why I think the best,
like the best comic ever.
Uh,
gotta be Gary Larson's the Pharcyde those things fucking hold up.
Is your read those back in the day?
He retired a long time ago,
but there's still stuff rate.
Right.
And then who did Doonesbury
that's like the political one,
right?
That's still,
is that his name?
Maybe?
Yeah.
What the fuck?
Who the fuck was,
is it Trudeau?
What's his first name?
Gary Trudeau.
Isn't that,
what's the name?
The Guy who runs Canada.
Justin.
That guy?
Yeah.
I never got Doonesbury.
I never like,
it was like too clever.
I was like,
okay.
Like I guess they're taken down Ronald Reagan or something,
but I don't know what the fuck they're talking about.
Doonesbury's weird too,
because they basically,
they
can hold hunter s Thompson and turned him into this.
They had a character that they were doing.
I think he wound up suing them.
Yeah.
There's his character is basically the exact same guy,
just slightly different.
And he was always like shooting off guns and doing a bunch of crazy shit.
I forget his name.
I forget the name of the guy.
They gave him a different name,
like uncle something or another.
Yeah,
but that was there.
I mean that was Garry Trudeau's take on hunter s Thompson and it wound up
driving hunters Thompson nuts.
Is this still real?
These still doing like he's doing Trump this.
That's 2017.
Wow.
Yeah.
But he,
um,
so he created this character that was basically the most exaggerated versions of
hunter s Thompson one hunters Thompson was fucking around and it sort of defined
who hunter s Thompson was too.
A lot of people because instead of being this brilliant journalist who you know
is great writer,
he also became this kind of like guide,
just shoots guns and was always drunk and then you fall into that trap.
I think comedians that have a persona like oftentimes fall,
like you know dice that's not,
his real name is Andrew Silverstein.
And the dice character was a part of his act.
He had a bunch of different things you can do.
Impressions,
we do Travolta impression.
Yeah,
phenomenal,
phenomenal Travolta impression.
And then the dice man became like a part of his act and then he just decided
that's the best part,
so I'm just going to do dice all the time.
And then he decided,
you know what?
Fuck live in like a regular person.
It was going to be dice all the time.
So he became the guy in his act.
I mean,
that's who he is like most of the time.
Oh yeah,
yeah.
Kinison Kennison under similar,
similar situation.
Never met Kennison Kinnison I mean he died well before I got into stand up,
but I'd never met dice and I've always like sang his praises.
Like I think the day the laughter died is one of the greatest comedy albums of
all time.
Uh,
and uh,
and I've just never met him.
He's great.
Yeah.
I'll let you do,
see you next time.
I see him at the store if you're there.
I've heard great stories.
He must like,
he must know who I am.
Oh yeah.
Yeah.
I once did.
Governor,
if he wasn't,
we'd be mad.
I wouldn't be mad.
I would be surprised just because I've spoken about him publicly,
that like if he was,
if he was wondering why he sold like a thousand copies of the day,
the laughter died after I like talked about it on a podcast.
Like he would hear that,
you know,
someone says something nice about you,
you find out.
Um,
but,
uh,
I was at governor's once and they were like all proud.
They were like,
dice was here last weekend and he left one of his gloves,
you know,
the fingerless gloves.
And I was just like,
give it to me.
What do I have to do to take this glove home?
But I'd still have it.
I like where it or I'm aware it around.
Sometimes it's fun.
Do you read and write jokes with it?
Oh,
well I'll,
I'll,
I'll walk around like just doing the,
doing a little bit.
Just one little o's.
But it's funny.
Cigarettes like loose.
Yeah.
But uh,
but yeah,
love,
love dogs.
But those characters,
when guys get lumped into a character,
when you get locked into that,
it can be very self-defining,
you know?
Of course Rick Kennison I think it was very self-define oh,
big time.
I the,
I thought about that when I was creating my persona.
It was like,
what's going to age?
Well?
Hmm.
You know,
like,
not like I think of a guy like Nick Swardson,
you know,
who's just like party all the time.
Like he's a college kid forever,
right?
It's like,
how long can you do that for?
You know what I mean?
It's like still kind of asked to do it and it's still great,
but I'm like,
are you enjoying this?
You know,
like I want to be able to like kind of hold onto my dignity,
you know,
does the best version of it.
Emo Phillips.
Yes.
That's the best example because it's like wow.
Like,
cause when he was a young sort of cute guy,
it was kind of strange to watch him go call medical.
I bliss when you're 60 though and you're doing that,
people are like,
hey man,
this is just weird.
Like bobcat talked about that like that bobcat had this moment where he stopped
being bobcat and people like,
hey man,
how can we not do it?
The scream.
He's like,
fuck you,
I'm not doing it.
I hate told me the best story ever.
He said,
he's in a,
he's at a comedy,
works in Denver doing a weekend and he's eaten shit every show and every show,
he's just bombing and everyone's going to do the voice,
do the voice.
And he's like,
no,
I'm not.
I don't do the voice anymore.
I'm not doing the voice late show Saturday.
Uh,
someone in the backyards were from Aurora,
do the voice for us.
And he goes,
Oh,
you're from Aurora.
At least you learn to sit in the back.
And he said,
and this is like a year after the shooting,
the movie theater.
Yes.
A year after that.
And he said the entire audience,
the entire audience just pretended he didn't say it,
they didn't boo,
they didn't laugh,
they just acted like nothing had happened.
And he did the rest of the show and he said him and made the whole weekend worth
it for him.
Just to say that.
Yeah,
dude,
I was speaking of which I was watching a video today,
you know how Youtube for whatever reason,
just starts recommending things and you'd click on it watching a video today on,
oh,
this is what it was.
I was looking at bulletproof clothing for whatever reason,
because I was like,
well,
I saw an ad on Instagram where this guy had a bulletproof hoodie on and it
looked like a regular hoodie and he shot himself.
Is that like a John Wick situation where it's like,
yes,
it's like,
it's like
Sonin in in the fabric.
Yeah.
So this guy had a regular hoodie and he shot himself in the gut with a a nine
millimeter,
just bang.
Wow.
Why was playing this video with like a regular Hoodie?
I was like,
this is crazy.
And this Hoodie,
it looked like a regular hoodie was,
but it's some sort of Kevlar or something.
So then it recommends this next thing and this next video that I watch is on
whether or not you should carry with a bullet in the chamber.
So it's this guy who's just speculating.
I liked it.
There's two kinds of people.
There's kind of people that thinks they're going to have enough time to rack a
bullet.
And there's a bunch of people that realize that when something happens,
it's like being in a accident happens quickly and you gotta be prepared.
You're not going to have enough time to rack a bullet.
And so there was this long discussion as to whether or not you should have a
bullet in the chamber or not when you conceal carry.
And he was talking about how this guy was open carrying,
but he could see that the guys,
the hammer was shut down on the pistol,
which means he's going to have to cock it cause it was a,
not a revolver but uh,
you know,
whatever.
And Autumn Semite what did,
what is it,
when you call,
what do you call one of those when you have to load it like that,
like a nine millimeter glock.
What is the difference?
Well,
one's a revolver.
Revolver revolves,
so it's on a revolver.
It's just a pistol.
Anyway,
he was saying because the way the hammer was,
he could tell that this guy,
uh,
you know,
he was going to have to pull that hammer back and was going to use that gun.
And I was like,
this is,
this is like next level thinking like these people,
everywhere you go,
someone's worrying about shooting you.
And then I go onto Twitter almost like this is synchronicity.
And Eric Weinstein is a friend of mine says,
is this the year where the debate is something,
something in terms of a,
is it appropriate to bring a loaded gun into a place where you worship now to
protect yourself?
Because there've been so many attacks on people and synagogues and churches and
mosques and I'm like,
fuck man,
what probably what?
What is happening here?
It's,
I mean it's bad.
I don't,
I'm not,
I'm not like a,
there's two more today.
What do you mean there's two more attacks today at synagogues.
It was,
one was in a church.
What were the ones that had,
that happened today?
There was two smaller ones.
There was no as the,
there was the church that was in San Diego this weekend.
No,
the,
uh,
the synagogue in San Diego this weekend.
But there was another one,
like this morning when I was reading the news,
Los Angeles.
Yes.
What was it for my 26 year old US army soldiers servers,
Afghanistan has been charged with plotting terror attacks in Los Angeles area,
a rally in Long Beach.
So it's on,
it's on the front page.
Is he had already got something like,
it's dumb sounds leaking through the video.
Did he do something or did he just got caught plot?
It says he was accused of targeting juices.
They walked to the synagogue,
police officer's a military facility and crowds at the Santa Monica pier.
I think there was another one too.
There was another one somewhere else might've been outside the country today.
It's like fuck,
like this shit is ramping up.
Yeah,
it's getting worse and worse.
Are you a gun guy?
I have guns.
I wouldn't say I'm a gun guy,
but I have them the hunting or like just don't really,
I have hunting guns and I have safety guns.
Like security guns are private,
you know,
personal protection guns.
But,
um,
I hunt with a bow and arrow mostly,
but of
course I'm not opposed to,
when you say,
of course being sarcastic,
I'm,
I'm not opposed to it.
What does this California synagogue attack latest?
Oh,
this is the,
they found a social media message,
I guess,
right
before it happened.
Of course.
Jesus Christ.
No,
I dunno.
I think there was one other one that I saw.
I believe it was in another country.
That's all right.
It's enough.
There's so many.
I know,
I know.
He just numb to it.
Well also that their chart targeting places of worship now,
like what the fuck man?
Do you have guns?
No.
Would you ever own one?
They make me uncomfortable.
Like I'm not like against it.
People want to have guns.
Okay.
I'm not done.
That's not a hill I'm going to die on.
But,
uh,
I think what's happening with the schools and churches is a,
is reprehensible and it's,
we are the only country where this really happens.
You know,
it was me.
Not Anymore.
It's happening,
you know,
uh,
around the world.
But it's,
it's much more often here.
Yeah.
Now there's,
there's certainly an argument for that.
The real problem is the guns are already there.
It's like,
how do you,
what do you do when you live in a country of 300 plus million people with 300
plus million guns?
Like how do you ever eradicate that?
How do you ever,
how do you shift the path that we seem to be on what you do?
I mean everything is like,
you know,
people talk about this and then like,
you know how,
how do we do what,
what is it,
the culture is,
is it the this and he turned on the TV and it's like a video game commercial or
a commercial for a movie and it's just a supermodel spinning around in circles
shooting everything she sees you.
You're like,
you don't think this is happened in the fact?
Like they just make it look so cool that if you want to be the hero,
you got to have a gun.
You know.
How about John Wick,
John Wick three coming out to my fucking favorite thing and I'm like,
this is the most,
the most glorifying gun shit ever.
But I love it.
I love it.
It is a problem.
I mean it has,
it hasn't made me turn to guns,
you know,
mean I wouldn't say that like video games,
make this video games or making people more violent.
I don't,
I don't believe that.
I don't know if there,
there's evidence to back that,
but I mean I've always loved,
you know,
James Bond movies,
things like where guns are are a,
are a big part of it and it's never made me want to pick one up.
Well,
there's
argument that that alleviates some of the need for violence that people like
seeing it and in seeing it and something like John Wick,
it actually relaxes people.
There's a real argument for that and there's a real argument that you could make
with that,
with video games too.
But that is not with everybody.
The problem is certain people are very susceptible to influence.
They're susceptible,
they're vulnerable to being influenced or excited in one particular direction,
whether it's,
uh,
excited to become radicalized and become a white nationalist and want to shoot
up,
you know,
uh,
whatever.
Figure out that whatever the group is or whether it's,
you know,
there's certain people that,
they'll see something in a movie or a video game.
It will make them want to act that out.
But they usually mentally ill.
I mean,
that's,
that's a real problem.
The real problem is mental illness at the type of person that could go into a
synagogue and just start shooting people.
That's a mentally ill person.
That's regardless of whether or not they have a gun or not.
That's a sick person.
So we have to figure out like what's causing this massive amount of mental
illness in this country.
Cause that's a big,
that's the guy in Aurora is a perfect example.
Like I was,
they knew he was sick.
They knew there was something really,
I mean if you see a photos of that fucking guy,
you look at his eyes,
he was completely batshit crazy.
I think it's something to,
to like when they,
when they,
now they've started to refuse to show the guy's face,
you know,
I mean,
they won't show it because they're like,
this guy's getting glory now and the next shooter wants to top that.
But I think they're getting a little bit smarter about it.
But what's the,
what's the quote?
No Man chooses evil because it's evil.
They only mistake it for happiness.
Mm.
Like I believe that.
Yeah.
That's a good quote.
They mistake it for happiness or they want other people to feel what they feel.
They want other people to suffer the way they're suffering.
Now with,
I mean,
when you ever have a giant country filled with people,
you're going to have a broad spectrum of people's experiences and so you're
going to have a certain number of people that are on the low end of experiences,
the worst experiences all the time,
sexual abuse,
physical abuse,
violence,
mental illness,
pills,
drugs,
this,
that boom.
But like Japan is one of the most unhappy countries in the world.
People at the suicide rate is off the charts,
but they take themselves out.
Yeah.
Know in America it's like,
let me,
who can I take with me?
I don't know what that,
what that is.
Well,
Japan emphasizes humility and uh,
they reward it.
Like if they emphasize being polite and orderly.
It's really interesting.
Um,
there was a dis piece I was watching on Youtube of these people that live in
cyber cafes,
that they have cyber cafes that are open 24 hours a day in Japan and they have
like this little cubicles that you taken there and they're just online on their
computer and they have all their things there and that's where they live and
they shower and they go back to their little cubicle.
But this woman was saying that it made her feel like she wasn't alone,
but she wasn't with people either.
Like she likes that,
that like she wants to know that there's people around her but she doesn't want
anybody in her life.
And I was like,
Ooh,
it was dark.
Yeah.
That's super fucking dark.
Sad.
Just the loneliness like that.
That's a giant issue apparently in Japan is how lonely people are,
which is incredibly ironic when you consider that it's probably one of the most
population dense places on earth and Tokyo at least.
Oh yeah.
I think they're just working their asses off.
I mean they fucking loved jumped in of trans,
they live for it.
Like it really is like the of countries that it's the least happy country and
the world.
Wow.
I think number like the happiest is like someone's Scandinavia,
Sweden or some shit.
Yeah.
Finland.
I think Finland like ranks very highly on that.
Yeah.
Why is it the thing I was watching said it was like a sense of community.
I think that them live together and like they eat their meals together as like a
neighborhood almost and they just like everyone contributes and they're just
happy and content.
That makes sense.
The numbers are smaller too.
I think that that helps also.
It's gorgeous up there.
That helps too.
A lot of factors there,
right?
Yeah.
Like what's a big city and Finland?
Helsinki.
How many people is at 50 how many people live in Helsinki?
50 50 50 I bet.
50 yeah,
I bet you're right.
I would.
I Bet Helsinki has 1.2 million people.
How many people think you have?
That's a wild guess.
I don't know why I had to put the 0.2 in there.
I'm hedging my bet if I was on the price is right.
It's the biggest,
but the thing I pull up doesn't say the second largest says 279,000 say he'll
think he does.
Well,
it doesn't.
You can't.
Doesn't.
If you Google population at the Helsinki,
it's the very first thing I had,
which was the biggest cities in Finland.
I figured it would.
It had it.
Oh five 58 558,000 yeah,
that ain't shit.
Wow.
That's it.
That's what they're happy.
It's basically like four boulders.
Yeah.
For Boulder.
Colorado's and it's a whole country.
Yeah.
You go to boulder then some of the nicest people ever.
Why 100,000 of them?
Is it hard to build their beautiful bolt?
Beautiful,
beautiful,
gorgeous,
great people.
Little on the social side,
but I get it a little too many Birkenstocks and tevarres and girls could use a
little bit more makeup.
Putting makeup on gals.
It's not load up a little.
It's not pronounced.
Tiva was Tevez.
Maybe it is divas.
I Dunno if I've even heard the word and figure weird leather sandals and shit,
but it's a cool place,
man.
But I think that's what you get.
If you live around nature,
you get a bunch of fit people that like hiking and had a lot of north face
jackets.
You know they got great weather.
Yeah,
yeah,
they'd really do.
They have blue blizzards and snow storms and shit,
but they also have like you'll,
it'll be 30 degrees in Denver or boulder and then the next day it'll be 60 yeah,
it doesn't make any sense.
Would you say Denver's the best comedy town in the country?
It's up there.
I fucking love it there.
I'm going there in August.
I'm doing that place again.
I fucking love it.
Yeah.
It's one of my favorite places on the planet period.
Like if I was going to leave la,
Denver's one of the spots that I would pick.
I think about like when I mentioned we leave,
where would I go and Denver's a demos at the top of the list.
I used to want to go to like Seattle or Portland and then I read that article,
that terrifying article about how light,
not just if one talks about the big one earthquake in La and they're like,
what's really going to fuck shit up is the tsunami that's going to happen on
that bottom line.
They're like Portland and Seattle.
We're going to be gone with that tsunami 100%.
Right?
100%.
Yeah.
It's just whether it's a hundred years from now or two [inaudible] but like I
just,
if we wake up one day and Seattle's gone 13 million people dead,
it goes deep into Washington state all the way to Tacoma.
The ocean goes to Tacoma.
Oh,
that there was an article they like talked about like what,
how it would happen like one,
one hand,
like minute by minute in Portland with this,
with this going on.
It was just terrified.
Yeah.
Fuck that.
Too risky.
Also seasonal depression is real.
Oh,
for sure.
I have a buddy of mine who moved to,
um,
he moved to Portland and started Jujitsu school out there and I was like
delight.
Like it.
He was like,
dude,
I fucking love it.
I go,
you don't Miss La at all.
He was like,
no,
I,
what about the reigns and me?
It's like,
no,
it's nothing.
Two years later,
he's back in La.
I go,
what happened?
He goes,
the fucking weather.
I go,
you liar.
You were trying to convince me.
You were trying to tell me and he started laughing.
He's like,
I'm convincing myself.
Yeah,
but he bought into it.
He goes,
I,
I go,
what happened is I came back one time and when it was rainy out there and it
wasn't rainy here and I was like,
what am I doing?
I go,
I'm less happy.
They're like,
it makes you less happy if it's raining all the time,
it makes you less happy rain.
If you live in La and it rains,
we're all happy like,
oh,
this is cool.
It's raining out of vitamin D is important.
It's not just vitamin D either.
It's just like a feeling.
You get like you're going to be cold and wet,
you're going to be cold and wet and you've got to bundle up and get inside
quickly.
Kid inside.
You can't just be free.
It can't be outside sitting in the grass eaten lunch.
So looking out and just relaxing.
Yeah,
I like my hammock.
Yeah.
Fuck that place.
And then fuck places that have like too much snow too,
like all the people that want to move back to New York.
I'm like,
you can keep that.
Good luck with that.
Yeah.
That New York,
the summer and the winters would kill me in New York.
I've been waiting for the subway when you're just like dripping sweat was just
brutal.
Chipping sweat with moist Piss,
smell everywhere,
that moisture,
but that's carrying those pis odor molecules and the subway.
Like what in the fuck are you people breathing in down here?
And I never got the rubber boots.
You know what I mean?
I was always just like had sneakers and be like trying to get,
trying to get to Fallon at like seven in the morning,
walking to the subway through the slush.
It was like it'd be beautiful,
wall was snowing and then as soon who was on the ground he would just like get
rid of this shit.
And now did you write for Fallon?
What was that kick like?
I mean it was a,
it was frustrating.
They didn't like,
because I started when he started late night with Jimmy Fallon's,
I was one of the first guys there and they didn't like any of my jokes.
Like it was just,
it was,
it was impossible to mean or just like this is going to make Jimmy unlikable.
Like it wasn't about being funny so much as like coming off as smart and uh,
and friendly,
you know,
unlikable the day I was there for a year
and then they barely used anything I ever did,
but they knew I was funny.
They liked me and I thought for some reason in my head I thought that if I quit
before a year that it like follow me.
People be like,
what happened with Fallon?
Why were you only there a year?
That like,
and then when I left,
it was like,
no one would have given a shit if I'd left after 10 weeks,
you know,
wouldn't have mattered at all.
Yeah,
it was,
it was good.
It's an interesting experience,
but I did not enjoy it.
Being a writer for other people's voices has got to be very difficult.
It's,
I mean,
for me it's impossible.
It's like I write in my voice and you either like it or you don't,
like I've written for Jimmy Kimmel,
Sarah Silverman,
and they'd,
if I love to joke,
they loved it too.
Uh,
but with Fallon,
that was not the case.
You know,
it was,
he was,
it was almost never like a,
he might,
he would laugh at the joke,
but he be like,
I can't say this.
I can't do it.
What are they trying to do?
Like what,
what is he trying to do?
And he's trying to be like Middle America,
like there's a market for that,
right?
Is that what it is?
He just wants everyone to love him,
you know,
he just wants everyone to,
uh,
everyone to love him.
And that's like not a bad trait to having a late night host.
Right.
Probably the best trait to having a late night host.
[inaudible] I'd like to see him drunk one day just shitting on everybody though.
I think it'd be hilarious.
Hilarious.
Does it do that?
Oh yeah.
Cause I mean I,
I've heard that he quit drinking.
I don't know if that's true,
but he would like,
he liked to get drunk and like,
and like shitty bars and like hang out and like with the,
with the staff and the crew,
like he was,
he's like a man of the people and he didn't just want to go home and drink.
He wanted to go out and go to some weird bar that was like in a subway that no
one knew about and have beers.
Like he was,
uh,
he was like a fun drunk,
you know.
But he did a lot.
Yeah.
There was always those rumors that he's got a problem.
She can balance.
Got a problem.
Yeah.
Do you think that's like the pressure of just being this like super friendly,
sweet guy on TV wanting everybody to love you?
They,
you're like,
oh my God,
get me a fucking drank so I can cut loose.
I'm,
I think that could be part of it,
you know?
That's why I was,
I was thought like with my persona,
like let's be the meanest person you can so that you can,
it allows you to be nice offstage.
You know,
you got cute kind of,
it gives you a little bit of distance.
But the guys who come off as like your best friend onstage tend to be monsters
off stay.
Some of them,
man.
Yeah.
I got another story.
I'll tell you when we get off the air about one of those.
Great.
Um,
well let's wrap this fucking thing up man.
you're special.
It's out tonight at midnight.
Yeah.
What's it called?
Fire in the maternity ward.
And you have Jesus,
once you think of that title,
you got to go with it every now and then when someone tells you a title,
a special and you have to,
well that was one of those.
So you got me.
Um,
you have several though.
So,
um,
what are the other ones that are available on Netflix now?
Thoughts and prayers is on Netflix firing the maternity ward comes out tonight.
I've got a podcast on a comedy central called the Jessalyn and Rosenthal Vanity
project.
Oh,
that's right.
Yeah.
Who is it with?
My friend Greg Rosenthal is a NFL analyst.
We've been best friends since college,
so we just kind of like,
we were supposed to talk about sports,
but we just fuck around.
Like we never call talk about scores.
Yeah.
It's fun.
Beautiful.
All right,
well,
uh,
good luck.
Good luck with a special thanks for doing this,
man.
I appreciate it.
Yeah.
Great comedy.
And finally be here.
Yeah,
for sure.
And uh,
I can't recommend his comedy enough.
It was for real.
If you're a fan of standup comedy,
Anthony Jeselnik is the shit,
so thank you,
sir.
Thank you,
John.
Bye everybody.